[Musique]
salut guillaume c'est le charmant et bah
écoute ça fait très plaisir de pouvoir
avoir enfin ce débat qu'on s'était
promis on avait promis de faire un débat
sur le sur le véganisme suite un autre
début de conversation sur la chaîne de
pavés gagnent
adrien de pavés galles on s'était
rencontré à cette occasion là et puis à
la fin de la fin de ton débat sur sa
chaîne on s'était dit que ça pourrait
être sympa d'organiser un débat sur nos
deux chaînes respectives
donc ça me fait très plaisir qu'on
puisse avoir cette occasion d'échanger
certains jeux ben écoute
étant donné que cette ce débat va être
publiée sur nos deux chaînes je te
propose qu'on se présentent chacun à nos
communautés respectives donc baasiste je
te laisse te présenter alors du coup moi
c'est guillaume ma chaîne youtube
s'appelle athlètes éthique comme
l'indiquent le nom très clairement et
explicitement je parle de nutrition et
de sport et je parle aussi des tic
donc voilà je suivais ghana nous la
raison d'autres débats et donc voilà je
veux par des tiques je fais du
militantisme c'est à dire que j'ai une
amie tente isme qui est basé sur la
défense des animaux
je parle d'anti spécisme je parle de
véganisme je parle d' animal isme et je
fais surtout de l'éducation et à dire
que je fais des débats l'éducation les
c'est d'informer les gens de les éduquer
de leur donner des outils en fait pour
changer leurs idées pour essayer de
réfléchir à des choses auxquelles n'ont
pas forcément réfléchi auparavant
notamment sur la condition animale
aujourd'hui et quelle est leur lien
entre quel est le lien entre ces
personnes là et le les lis justement
l'éthique animale est ce qu'ils ont déjà
songé à ces questions est ce qu'ils sont
déjà posés justement les questions de
savoir si
si le traitement qu'on inflige aux
animaux aujourd'hui quelque chose des
tickets quelque chose de moralement
acceptable justifiable etc etc
ok donc bah moi c'est charles de la
chaîne le précepteur et je propose
essentiellement des vidéos de pédagogie
de philosophie également et je pense que
ce qui finalement est le dénominateur
commun nos deux chaînes c'est une
certaine pédagogie la volonté de
d'expliquer les choses et de pas
forcément avoir des avis péremptoire et
définitif donc laissé aussi la plaça à
la contradiction et je pense que c'est
ça aussi qui a fait qu'on a eu envie
discuter ensemble c'est à dire qu'on va
pour se présenter un petit peu par
rapport à cet aspect là tu es légal chez
les militants vega est ce que est ce que
l'expression militants dégâts ne te
correspond je préfère disant
l'expression militante pour les droits
des animaux
si tu peux faire parce qu'on peut être
vegan sans forcément être militant c'est
vrai et le véganisme n'est pas forcément
une position militante en soi mais donc
moi je préfère me qualifier de militants
pour les droits des animaux aussi parce
que ça inclut la notion de droit et ça
inclut la notion d' animaux alors que
quand on parle de véganisme on pense pas
forcément aux animaux et on pense pas
forcément à quelque chose de de droit ou
de l'égalité et ses terres et ses
travers et moi je devais définir et par
rapport à ça comme étant un nombre égal
c'est à dire je ne suis pas un anti
végal je ne suis pas opposé au mode de
vie aux modes de consommation des vegan
mais je ne le suis pas trop personnel
donc ce qui fait que forcément ben je
vais avoir des billets 1 2 dans ma
manière évidemment de de me positionner
par rapport aux véganisme mais je pense
que bon ben ça c'est quelque chose on a
discuté hors antenne
on est d'accord aussi pour se dire qu'on
n'avait pas forcément besoin d'être
d'accord sur tout il y aura de
l'opposition dans ce débat en tout cas
dans cette discussion il y aura des
désaccords automatiquement qu on
assumera etc on s'exposera mais qu on
s'exposera avec un esprit constructif de
bienveillance on sera pas là pour se
clasher connaît la fameuse le sait la
fameuse phrase ce n'est pas un clash
généralement c'est mauvais signe
mais là pour une 1re manche pense qu'on
peut le dire ce n'est pas un clash
par contre on ne s'interdira pas
d'exprimer nos oppositions parce que là
guillaume comme moi ne sommes pas des
personnes susceptibles en tout cas sur
le plan des idées
et comme on n'a pas prévu de s'attaquer
personnellement
a priori on n'aura pas besoin disons de
retenir nos contre-arguments l'un envers
l'autre
est ce que est ce que tu vas lire ce que
je veux dire non seulement je valide
mais en plus je trouve que c'est quelque
chose de super important je te demande
pour apporter la contradiction même
quand on a des convictions qui sont
assez fortes c'est toujours intéressant
d'avoir la contradiction en face ne
serait ce que pour se connaître soi-même
en question et se demander si on est
dans la bonne direction
et peut-être s'il ya des bons arguments
aussi en face dans lequel cas et c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant de soi même
se remettre en question justement donc
c'est important de et du coup n'hésite
surtout pas en tout cas à apporter la
contradiction
quels que soient les arguments que je
peux proposer en tout cas c'était les
arguments toi qui deviennent pour me
contredire très bien voilà je pense que
c'est ça un peu l'idée de se dire ce
qu'on pense franchement ne pas faire
semblant et en même temps ne pas être
dans l'opposition systématique par
principe
c'est à dire que si à un moment donné je
trouve ton propos convaincants des
réponses convaincantes
je n'hésiterais pas à le dire et puis
bah on verra bien où ça où ça nous mène
à de toute façon le but c'est aussi
d'échanger de manière libre alors pour
pour débuter ce débat cet entretien en
tout cas je vais poser une question
toute simple qui est peux tu nous
expliquer pourquoi tu es végal quelles
sont les raisons éthiques puisqu'on va
essentiellement parlé d'éthique animal
des raisons éthiques pour lesquelles tu
es végal et et pour lesquels tu promeut
le véganisme ouais alors pourquoi je
suis devenu vegan alors pour résumer je
dirais aux relativement trivialement
j'ai toujours plus ou moins considéré
que torturés ou infliger des souffrances
faire souffrir un animal dans l'unique
but d'en tirer une satisfaction
personnelle était quelque chose de
condamnable et d'injuste donc forcément
j'avais tendance à blâmer assez
facilement des pratiques comme la
corrida comme le massacre par exemple
des dauphins sur les ou des cétacés sur
les îles féroé au japon le braconnage la
chasse a trop fait et cetera et cetera
donc en fait si tu veux que des
pratiques auxquelles je ne participe est
auxquel je ne participais pas moi même
et donc en fait qu'il m'était facile de
remettre en question parce que ça me
posais pas moi personnellement de me
remettre en question ce tuyau et puis
et je précise que si des papes ce n'est
pas l'expression d'un amour
inconditionnel des animaux tu vois quand
je quand je me levais contre ça c'était
j'ai jamais particulièrement aimé les
animaux pas forcément plus qu'une
personne qui autres personnes ce qui est
plus l'expression d'une démarche logique
et rationnel et raisonnable de dire
pourquoi allait faire ça c'est animaux
alors qu'ils nous ont rien fait qu'est
ce qui nous donne le droit d'aller les
attaquer et c est de ne pas les laisser
vivre on paye finalement quelque chose
d'assez banal
et puis si rude quand tu affirmes que tu
que les animaux qu'il soit humain ou non
devraient avoir le droit à un minimum de
respect lequel un pic au moins je pense
de ne pas être considérée comme une
marchandise
ce qui d'un point de vue humain par
exemple serait quand même eu
une des plus récentes qui serait d'un
point de vue humain par exemple une
violation
assez assez explicite de nos libertés
fondamentales
en tout cas des droits de l'homme ni a
fortiori d'être mise à mort il ya
forcément un moment où tu te poses la
question et tu te dis est ce que quand
je mange des animaux
c'est un besoin à ce que je fais
vraiment par besoin parce que si c'est
pas le cas si ce n'est pas une nécessité
alors forcément tu te retrouves dans une
espèce de contradiction logique une
espèce de d'incohérences assez énorme
dhr ton système de valeurs et forcément
tes actions en fait son plus aligné à
tes convictions et ça c'est un problème
quand tu prends une pratique du doigt
alors que tu alors que tu emploies entre
guillemets les mêmes raisons c'est à
dire peut-être un plaisir peut-être un
côté traditionnel le culturel toi même
dans ton système de d'actions et du coup
cette question puisqu'il peut paraître
assez banal le dirai ce que je mange des
animaux par besoin ou pas c'est quand
même une question qui pour moi vran
ferme si tu veux une un poids de
responsabilités assez énorme une gravité
assez grande dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui quand même on est dans une
société où on tue
ne serait-ce qu'en france à peu près un
peu plus d'un milliard d'animaux par an
soit environ 3 millions par jour donc
c'est pas banal de se dire est ce qu on
fait ça parce qu'on en a besoin parce
que c'est pour un plaisir ou quelque
chose de culturel traditionnel et
caetera et c est donc après quelques
recherches tu te rends compte que tu
peux vivre en bonne santé sans manger
d'animaux sans manger de produits
laitiers de exeter et c'est bien sûr la
condition de faire ça avec un minimum de
réflexion et avec une une
supplémentation adéquat selon les
individus et puis et puis évidemment
quand tu peux ensuite que boycotter bain
tout ce qui est infrastructure qui
utilisent des animaux pour le
divertissement comme les cirques par
exemple avec animaux sauvages ou animaux
en général ce sont obligés de boycotter
aussi tout ce qui est fou rire au
reporter porter la peau des animaux leur
fourrure etc etc
et puis bien sûr éviter les cosmétiques
et sont testés sur animaux
donc après voilà tu es dans une espèce
de cesser d'être en fait le plus
cohérent possible par rapport à ton
système de morale et de valeurs
ok bon alors tu t'en doutes il ya
beaucoup de choses que tu as dit sur
lesquels j'ai envie de réagir
forcément forcément belle mais c'est
très bien et il se trouve que c'est bien
le format qu'on a choisie c'est-à-dire
de se laisser terminer un de cons
efficient de dire ce qu'on avait à dire
avant de pouvoir réagir un même si après
on s'interdit pas de seins terme de
temps en temps
bon on a prévu de faire un débat sur
l'éthique animale est plutôt la
philosophie la philosophie morale mais
c'est vrai que je trouvais intéressant
aussi peut-être d'aborder très
rapidement la question des besoins
puisque tu la pause cela soulève la
question des besoins physiologiques je
t'avouerai très sincèrement que c'est
une question à laquelle je fais assez
sensible la question des besoins
physiologiques parce que autant je
comprends l'idée qu'on veuille minimiser
la souffrance animale et qu'on soit prêt
à faire des sacrifices en termes de
plaisir autant sur la question du besoin
ça me paraît plus délicat parce que les
animaux sont des êtres programmé pour la
survie est donc et ça peut paraître un
petit peu choquant on fera tout pour
survivre
même si c'est au détriment des êtres
animaux et ça ça me paraît être entre
guillemets une loi de la nature
donc à partir de là quand tu me parles
quand tu dis que finalement manger de la
viande n'est pas nécessaire à nos
besoins physiologiques
j'arrive à à entendre l'argument mais
pas totalement parce que est ce qu'il
n'ya pas malgré tout des problèmes de
carences même alors on parle de la
supplémentation ok on a les moyens
technologiques de pouvoir se
supplémenter mais est-ce qu'un sportif
et je dis ça parce que tu es la chaîne
s'appelle athlétique donc tu as ce point
commun avec moi d'être un sportif est ce
qu'un sportif n'a pas malgré tout
beaucoup plus de difficultés à rester en
bonne santé
est-ce qu'il n'est pas plus sujet à des
blessures un des maladies lorsqu'il ne
peut pas consommer de la viande c'est à
dire certains nutriments dont la
biodisponibilité selon moi d'après mes
connaissances ne se retrouve pas dans un
mode d'alimentation des gal écoute le je
pourrais te répondre à ça maintenant le
danseur dans ce genre de débat sur la
nutrition
c'est vrai que c'est difficile d'avancer
les arguments sans présenter des études
scientifiques etc etc et
des études scientifiques y en a beaucoup
il ya aussi beaucoup de sportifs
végétalien aujourd'hui qui sont à un
niveau parfois extrêmement élevés
parfois relativement élevé pour les
sportifs comme lewis hamilton par
exemple qui qui est champion de formule
1 qui est complètement végétalien et et
4 et qui est certes pilote de formule 1
fia de formule 1 c'est s'il ya un sport
qui est extrêmement demandant un point
de vue physique ou ses d'un point de vue
mental tu as d'autres sportifs qui vont
être quasiment végétaliens ou en tout
cas végétarien clairement par exemple
des gens comme djokovic comme serena
williams tu as des body builder qui vont
être avoir des physiques assez
exceptionnel et qui sont 100% végétalien
tu as des gens comme limaille delgado
comme john venus comme tories washington
tu vas ce champion de wight lifting
américain qui s'appelle il me semble
kendrick faris qui avait battu un record
aux jeux olympiques j'ai pu sur quels
exercices mais il y avait battu un
record olympique en haltérophilie qui
est 100% végétalien depuis un moment où
là tu as des sportifs comme ça
maintenant s'arrêter des anecdotes et il
ya que finalement des études
scientifiques qui peuvent qui peuvent
corroborer un petit peu cette vision là
qu'on peut être 100 % des italiens et en
même temps avoir un niveau extrêmement
élevé dans un sport une discipline
sportive quelle qu'elle soit et et voilà
en ce qui concerne le côté nutrition
clairement aujourd'hui tu as des
institutions qui qu'ils disent de
manière explicite noir sur blanc que
l'alimentation végétalienne peut être
adapté à tous les pour toutes les
personnes à tous les âges de la vie
tu vois ce qui s'appelle la société
l'academy of nutrition et diététique ce
qu'un organisme américain qui regroupe
il me semble plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de
nutritionniste est qui et qui a
justement publié en une un article
une étude scientifique où justement ils
disent que le vitalisme à la condition
qu'il soit bien réfléchi bien réalisé et
c'est bien organisé
même si en réalité c'est vraiment pas si
difficile que ça est adaptée à toutes
les périodes de la vie font même des
femmes enceintes même les personnes très
âgées et même les nouveau-nés cetera et
cetera donc donc voila apres ya aucun
nutriment en dehors de la bidouze tu ne
peux pas trouver dans l'alimentation
végétale donc la b12 effectivement
aujourd'hui comme il y en a pas deux
sources végétales
on est obligé de l'avoir en tant que
supplément malgré tout il est vrai aussi
que un certain nombre d'animaux
d'élevage fonds supplémentaires
également b2 donc voilà effectivement
sur sur ce nutriment c'est important si
on évite à rien de se supplémenter ça
c'est sûr après pour les autres tout ce
qui est faire tout ce qui est protéines
tout ce qui est enfin tout nutriments
voilà c'est la lanterne des vitamines et
en principe n'a aucun souci parce qu'on
trouve tout dans les végétaux la b12 la
vitamine b12 alors je te le dis voilà en
toute transparence je vais pas appuyé
sur cet argument là pour dire que le
régime alimentaire des gannes n'est pas
viable parce qu'il manquerait cette
cette composante
de la vitamine b12 mais tu vois je pense
que c'est pas juste la b12 c'est à dire
que par exemple je prends l'exemple de
la créatine parce que tu me parlais des
bodybuilders je sais pour connaître un
petit peu un petit peu ce milieu là que
de toute façon le bodybuilding et
gangréné par le dopage comme comme le
font d'autres sports et qu'en réalité
gagner une compétition de bodybuilding
suppose de se doper
en réalité c'est à dire que là on est au
delà de prendre sa protéines en poudre
et même sa création en poudre mais même
si on s'arrête au simple niveau de la
créatine à parce que je précise pour les
gens qui ne sont pas familiers du sport
et de la musculation prendre des
protéines et prendre de la créatine ça
ne s'appelle pas du dopage ça s'appelle
de la supplémentation de la
complémentation parce que la créatine on
la produit naturellement mais la
créatine
on la retrouve dans la viande animale
alors je sais j'ai fait une petite
recherche chilien figure toi j'ai
découvert une chose on la retrouve aussi
dans les cerises mais je n'aime pas
voilà mais à un niveau extrêmement
faible
extrêmement faible mais on la retrouve
quand même mais c'est vrai que pour la
construction musculaire je me suis dit
ça me semble compliqué en tout cas sur
la longue durée de pouvoir se construire
un physique solide
si on ne consomme pas de créatine qu'on
trouve uniquement dans la viande
alors je dis pas que le but de l'homme
c'est de devenir un autre sur ce n est
guère dis simplement que le renforcement
musculaire a aussi des vertus au niveau
de la santé et que je comprendrais que
quelqu'un refuse d'adopter un mode
d'alimentation vegan parce qu'il se dit
je préfère rester en bonne santé et j'ai
statistiquement plus de chance de rester
en bonne santé si j'ai des nutriments
bio disponibles dans la viande plutôt
que si je dois m'en priver voilà est-ce
que qu'est ce que tu penses de ça alors
pour ce qui est de du côté renforcement
musculaire ou plutôt on va dire prise de
masse musculaire pour moi clairement si
on d'un point de vue d'un pendu pour
recommencer nutritionnelle le il me
semble même avoir vu une est utilisée
que la créatine utilisé par les par les
sportifs italiens avaient un effet
supérieures à celles à l'utilisation
faite par d
sportif qui mange des animaux pour la
simple et bonne raison que par absence
de créatine le fait en prenant ce
supplément avait cette sorte de c'est
une sorte de d'intensification encore
plus grande de l'effet de la créatine
pour essayer de retrouver cette étude et
te l'envoyer l'entente sera peut être
possible mais mais après je viens
d'entendre je veux bien le croire parce
que c'est pas le seul cas où une
supplémentation décuplerait ses effets
par rapport à quelqu'un qui en
consommeraient déjà c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qu'on remarque souvent
mais on est d'accord que la créatine ans
que l'on parle d'une créatine de
synthèse et que dans ce cas là le
véganisme présuppose aussi et c'est pas
une critique c'est juste pour qu'on soit
d'accord ça présuppose quand même que en
termes d'alimentation de synthèse on
soit au point pour pouvoir proposer ce
genre de complément mais la vérité c'est
que si tu veux enfin toi même tu dois
savoir puisque tu fréquentes un peu le
milieu de la musculation mais mes séries
dans le milieu la musculation
la plupart des gens consomment de la
créatine en poudre et de la protéine en
poudre alors même qu'ils sont alors même
qu'ils consomment de la viande de
manière extrêmement régulière notamment
dans le fait de la musculation et donc
voilà donc ça c'est la première chose
après pour le point de vue de la morale
clairement ça me semble extrêmement
compliqué de dire mais même même avant
tu vois même je pense même qu'avant
d'être végétalien je pense pas avant
d'être vegan je pense pas que j'aurais
pu tenir là la position de dire je lave
que le fait l'acte de tuer un animal
pour le manger à la limite j'aurais pu
dire d'un point de vue purement santé
d'accord mais d'un point de vue prendre
de la masse musculaire pour le 2 que
peut apporter
l'effet de la créatine je pense que
j'aurais pu dire même cette position je
pense que je l'aurais pas tenues
aventure à moi surtout que le
la créatine attention pour les gens qui
nous écoutent prend de la créatine c'est
pas ça reste mais même la bottine en
poudre 1 ça reste des suppléments et
c'est pas prendre de la créatine ou la
protéine en poudre qui va tout d'un coup
décupler la prise de masse musculaire et
que cet art etc
la créatine c'est avant tout ne savent
en tout quelque chose qui permet de de
se dépasser encore plus dans les ford
est donc d'avoir aidé d'avoir des effets
bénéfiques sur le niveau des fibres
musculaires puisque ça permet de
détruire encore plus les fibres et donc
de leur permettre encore plus de
récupérer et de musulmans de voix la
bombe lors de toute façon c'était
presque une parenthèse cette question de
la nuit trimestre que bon déjà à titre
personnel je ne suis pas du tout un
expert dans ce domaine là mais c'était
une manière de rebondir sur ce ton
propos alors parmi ce que tu as dis donc
tu as parlé delà de la souffrance soit
parlé de la torture qu'on inflige aux
animaux évidemment j'ai tiqué pourquoi
j'ai ticket parce que il me semble qu'il
y a très souvent de la part de certains
vegan une utilisation du vocabulaire qui
est orienté mais à la limite pourquoi
pas par définition quand on parle on est
orienté dans notre dans notre propos
mais je vois dans le mot torture l'idée
d'intention je vois l'idée de sadisme de
cruauté et j'ai l'impression que c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas conforme à
la réalité de ce qu'ils mangent de la
viande c'est à dire que autant je peux
entendre qu'on considère la corrida
comme comme une mise en scène du sadisme
et de l'art et de la souffrance animale
autant celui qui mange son steak qu'il
achète en supermarché je lui
reprocherais pas de participer
activement à la torture animale
moi je lui reprocherais autre chose dont
on parlera tout à l'heure c'est de ne
pas avoir conscience de ce qu'il a dans
son assiette et de pas avoir conscience
que c'est un animal en fait est que le
poisson qu'on fait c'est la fameuse
blague tu demandes un enfant d'école
primaire à quoi ça ressemble un poisson
il te fait un rectangle parce que pour
lui c'est du poisson pané
c'est ça le poisson bon pour moi ça ça
relève d'un autre problème mais celui
qui mange de la viande selon moi on peut
pas le on peut pas lui dire qu'ils
participent à la torture des animaux
parce que je pense que ce serait lui
attribuer une culpabilité dans
l'intention qu'il
pas ou alors moi pour le coup quand j'ai
parlé au début il me semble de torture
et de faire souffrir les animaux je
parlais effectivement je parlais pas
encore du cas de la consommation je
parlais du cas de moi quand j'étais
avant d'être légal justement quand je
vais justement les massacre des dauphins
etc
je pensais pour moi c'était de la
torture etc après je passe je parlais
d'une manière générale ils tous les
animaux qui sont mangés ne sont pas
nécessairement torture et maintenant 80
% des animaux en france gagne élevages
intensifs
tout dépend de ta conception de la
torture et de la conception des gens en
général de la torture maintenant j'ai
remarqué une chose justement par rapport
au vocabulaire que j'emploie par pas un
moment parfois il suffit d'une simple
description de la réalité
par exemple si je dis si je dis ben pas
rentrer les gens n'aiment pas dire que
je n'aime pas dire que quand je parle
dégorgement des animaux qu'ils ne
passent à l'égorgement des animaux mais
les animaux ils sont soient électrocutés
soit par électronarcose soit justement
je vais te faire une description j'ai de
faire notamment une déclaration
descriptif de ce qui se passe les
animaux certains animaux pour avant
d'être d'être égorgé on prend ce qu'on
appelle un milieu un pistolet matador on
le retire dans le crâne une tige
perforantes en acier après on les
suspend à des chaînes ont les égorge sas
et descriptifs en fait c'est c'est
pajemploi pas un vocabulaire
spécialement pour choquer et c'est
vraiment une description la pratique et
cette description de la pratique el jem
et pourquoi elle gêne parce que je pense
il y a justement cette espèce de 2,2
soit de refus d'accepter la réalité de
ce qui se passe parce qu'on y participe
ou soit une espèce de jeu de dénis de
dire non ça ne se passe pas comme ça ou
alors il peut y avoir effectivement
aussi l'ignorance il ya peut-être des
gens il ya sûrement même des gens qui ne
savent pas forcément voilà comment ça se
passe dans les abattoirs que comment qui
ne connaissent pas l'électronarcose qui
savent pas que certains cochons par
exemple il me semble que c'est dans les
dents les 4 millions il me semble par an
en france sont tués dans des chambres à
gaz par exemple mais
grande proposer ce vocabulaire là c'est
une description message n voilà ça me
choque pas qu'on emploie les termes
descriptifs réels c'est à dire que le
terme de mise à mort ne me dérangerait
pas tu vois par contre c'est vrai que le
mot torture j'ai tendance à y voir si tu
veux une volonté de qualifier les
auteurs de ces mises à mort comme des
tortionnaires torture tortionnaires il
ya cette idée là après évidemment je
veux pas te reprocher d'employer des
termes qui correspondent à ta conception
de la pratique en question
sait on est bien d'accord mais par
contre ça m'amène sur finalement une
autre question que j'avais envie de te
poser et l'a peut-être qu on va pouvoir
un peu échangé des arguments c'est toi
en tant que vegan est ce que est ce que
tu combats la souffrance animale
est-ce que tu combat l'exploitation
animale la mise à mort animal tu vois ce
que je veux dire est ce qu'il ya une
hiérarchie dans tout ça voilà ça
m'intéresserait de d'avoir ta réponse là
dessus bien sûr alors là ça va être ma
conception à moi mais parce que tu as
effectivement tu vas tu peux
effectivement avoir des positions
différentes selon les militants moi j'ai
donné donc ma position à moi
moi ce que je combats c'est justement
cette idée que on peut faire subir des
choses à des animaux compterait pas
subir à des êtres humains
tu vois par exemple donc en gros moi
quand je dis que justement que je milite
pour les droits des animaux
c'est que je milite pour leur donner des
droits que je dirais que j'appellerais
fondamentaux donc d'espèces de libertés
fondamentales et pour moi dans la notion
de droit fondamental il est évident que
la vie l'intégrité corporelle et le fait
de ne pas être traité comme une
marchandise pure et simple sont des
droits fondamentaux
c'est le cas évidemment pour des humains
pour moi c'est les droits qu'on devrait
justement donner à ces animaux et donc
effectivement ça inclut le fait de ne
pas les tuer
en tout cas elle tué avec préméditation
et volontairement ça inclut le fait
justement de ne pas porter atteinte à
leur intégrité physique
donc effectivement ça peut être le fait
justement autant les frapper que que
leur couper le bec ou où les castrer
aviv 47 cas des porcelets tu vois et
donc voilà effectivement ce côté faire
souffrir
il ya ce côté tués et il ya ce côté
justement exploités qui justement amène
à cette notion de d'être traité comme un
objet comme une marchandise quelque
chose qui n'a pas vraiment de chose qui
n'a pas de valeur morale en fait mais
qui a une valeur marchande
tu vois c'est c'est ça que c'est ça que
je combats alors maintenant est-ce que
c'est assez explicite pour toi en tout
cas tu aurais bien laisser des fois tu
penses que je suis à côté la question
d'une palme d'or noir non ça répond à la
question et du coup ça va m'amener
justement là pour le coup à à te donner
à te porter la contradiction sur la
notion de droits des animaux
alors pour moi l'expression droits des
animaux
si tu veux elle n'a pas réellement de
sens et je vais essayer d'expliquer un
petit peu pourquoi je pense que ça n'a
pas vraiment de sens parce que qu'est ce
qu'on appelle le droit donc le droit au
sens général c'est ce qui régit les
comportements au sein d'une société
humaine
donc c'est à dire c'est un système de
normes et le droit c'est une invention
culturelle des êtres humains c'est à
dire que si on prend l'hypothèse d'un
état de nature où il n'y aurait pas
d'état pas de société il n'y a pas de
loi donc ça veut dire c'est finalement
le la loi du plus fort
et puis un moment donné mais peut-être
que les êtres humains on se sont dit que
c'était une situation qui n'était pas
tenable alors là je renvoie les
auditeurs éventuellement intéressé aux
travaux de thomas hobbes le philosophe
du xviie siècle qui parlait de cet état
de nature comme étant un état de guerre
de tous contre tous c'est la guerre
permanente de tous contre tous tu sais
c'est celui qui a repris cette phrase
l'homme est un loup pour l'homme
donc les hommes se sont mis d'accord ils
ont passé un pacte le pacte social pour
dire on va renoncer à cette liberté
absolue qui finalement nous pénalise
puisque si l'autre n'a pas de frein à sa
liberté il peut faire ce qu'il veut il
veut me tuer donc c'est la peur de la
mort violente en réalité qui aurait
poussé des hommes a créé le droit et le
droit c'est de dire
eh bien je ne peux pas empiéter sur la
liberté de l'autre je ne peux pas nuire
à autrui et c est tout ça à constituer
ce qu'on a appelé le droit le droit est
une création le droit n'est pas naturel
par essence ce qui est naturel c'est la
loi du plus fort le droit ce sont des
citoyens des individus qui se mettent
d'accord pour s'octroyer se reconnaître
des droits et les uns envers les autres
et parce qu'il se donne des droits il se
donne des devoirs également l'expression
droits des animaux me paraît un non sens
parce que ça supposerait qu'on pourrait
donner aux animaux des devoirs puisque
le droit s'accompagne toujours du devoir
or il me paraît évident qu'on ne peut
pas donner de devoirs à des animaux donc
s'ils ne peuvent pas avoir de devoir ils
ne peuvent pas avoir de droit non plus
ce sont les deux faces de la même pièce
en réalité le droit et le devoir et j'en
terminerai life te laisserais évidemment
répondre c'est l'idée que ce n'est pas
parce qu'on refuse l'idée de droits
animaux qu'on pense qu'on a le droit de
faire ce qu'on veut avec les animaux par
exemple à titre personnel je suis contre
la torture animale
je suis contre la maltraitance inutile d
animaux vraiment mais viscéralement sa
limite ça me fait mal au ventre si je
vois l'animal se faire torturer
mais pour autant je n'irai pas employé
l'expression de droits des animaux
j'irai parler d'un de voir des êtres
humains de respecter les animaux un
devoir de l'être humain de ne pas faire
souffrir des êtres qui n'ont rien
demandé
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est
vraiment presque une question de
vocabulaire l'expression droits des
animaux ne paraît pas viable
conceptuellement ouais alors il ya
plusieurs choses tu as dit il à
l'épisode chose sur lequel je vais
revenir
je vais commencer par la dernière sinon
je vais l'aube il est je le sais quand
tu dis qu'on a effectivement qu'on à la
limite si on ne donnaient pas de droit
aux animaux sert de le droit de les
protéger et c'est même si les ces droits
existent déjà pour certains animaux
comme les animaux de compagnie par
exemple il mène d'ailleurs maintenant
pour certains aux autres animaux mais
bref
il ya ce côté c'est sous-entendre que
l'être humain accepterait ou en tout cas
se comporteraient face à ses devoirs qui
saurait css qui serait ss oui qui serait
de justement de ne pas de ne pas
torturer ses animaux ou de ne pas les
blesser il allait faire souffrir
inutilement et c'est un accès pour ça ce
que je peux dire c'est que on a déjà des
cas où des gens alors même que certains
animaux de compagnie par exemple sont
protégées par des droits alors même que
c'est le cas il ya quand même malgré
tout des gens qui vont aller les
torturer ses convois par exemple des
fois dans des fait divers on voit telle
personne à voulais un chien par exemple
ou à eux frapper un ou à taper dans un
châle à jeter par la fenêtre etc est
taxé des races et celle des faits divers
qu'on peut voir trente ans et du coup du
coup imaginons une seule seconde qu'on
enlève même des droits aux animaux qui
sont déjà protégés jeu pour moi ça me
paraît extrêmement dangereux en fait de
d'imaginer une seule seconde que les
êtres humains vont se plier à des
devoirs et non pas à des droits en vertu
en ce qui concerne leur comportement
vis-à-vis d'autres d'autres animaux même
entre eux en fait tu vois je me dis que
si demain on estime par exemple que les
êtres humains ont le devoir de ne pas
tuer de ne pas voler de ne pas violer
etc etc
quand bien même certains de voir si on
n'applique pas des droits pour protéger
les personnes il me semble évident qu'il
y aura des gens de toute façon qu'ils
iront voler tuer etc etc c'est déjà le
cas alors même qu'on a des droits
donc tu vois moi je me ferais je ne me
fierais pas trop en tout cas à cette
idée que parce qu'on a des devoir c'est
suffisant pour protéger d'éventuelles
victimes de nos comportements et ensuite
lorsque tu disais avant en fait je sais
pas si on parle de droits morale ou de
droit légal parce que moi quand je dis
de droits des animaux évidemment heavy
ific
évidemment je veux que ce soit quelque
chose de légal ce soin à lee légiférer
mais à la base pour moi ils ont un droit
un droit moral le droit moral inclus
ensuite en droit légal pour être de
protection c'est vrai qu'on n'est
c'est aussi bien coin et beaucoup de
gens le savent très bien c'est que
l'égalité n'est pas synonyme de morale
et de moralité et d'éthique
on est énormément d'exemple dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
deux choses qui était légal et que l'on
condamne aujourd'hui moralement de
manière complètement
enfin de manière complètement normal
enfin ça nous paraît par exemple des
choses comme des choses comme il n'y a
pas si longtemps encore en décapiter des
gens sur les places publiques
il n'y a pas si longtemps on a eu des
choses comme la traite des noirs par
exemple il n'ya pas si longtemps on
voulait des gens sur les places
publiques et cetera et cetera c'était
des sociétés illégales
pour autant est-ce qu'on peut dire
qu'une chose parce qu'elle était légale
était moral est donc voila moi ce que je
dis c'est que on est toujours là la loi
si tu veux sera toujours en retard pour
moi sur la morale sur la protection des
individus
ça a été le cas pour les femmes c'était
le cas pour les homosexuels c'était le
cas pour les personnes de couleur
c'est aujourd'hui le cas pour les
animaux c'est le sujet c'est je pense
que c'est un des grands sujets du moment
enfin du moment depuis effectivement on
va peut-être en parler mais depuis en
tout cas peter singer et même un petit
peu avant donc voila moi c'est vraiment
quand je parle de droit je parle d'abord
de loi morale qui doit qui doit se
concrétiser par l'endroit de légal
effectivement qui puisse protéger ces
individus que sont les animaux non
humains
ok alors
je dirais il ya deux choses sur
lesquelles je vais réagir pour la chose
c'est que je maintiens que la notion de
droit ne peut pas correspondre ne peut
pas s'appliquer aux animaux dans la
mesure où même si je comprends l'idée de
vouloir entre guillemets ajouté une
deuxième couche de protection en parlant
de droit le fait est que ça ne
fonctionne pas parce que la notion même
de droit présuppose que l'individu qui a
des droits a conscience de ses droits
les droits ont les exercent et pour les
exercices faut en avoir conscience c'est
le sait le c'est le minimum
parce que je veux dire parler du droit
des animaux que ce soit au niveau moral
ou au niveau légal me paraît être un
abus de langage c'est tout simplement un
abus de langage que je peux comprendre
dans l'esprit mais qui dans les faits
c'est à dire à la lettre du concept ne
fonctionne pas tu vois je prendre une
analogie un petit peu caricatural c'est
de dire c'est pas parce que tu n'as pas
le sait pas parce que il est interdit de
voler la voiture du voisin que ça veut
dire que la voiture a des droits
ça veut simplement dire que tu as le
devoir de respecter la propriété
d'autrui et de la même façon c'est pas
parce que il est mal de frapper son
chien que ça veut dire que tout à coup
le chien se met à avoir des droits
ça veut simplement dire que d'un point
de vue humain parce qu on est bien dans
le droit c'est bien quelque chose qui
s'applique à l'humain et le devoir d'un
point de vue humain on considère qu'il
est malvenu qu'il est préjudiciable de
faire souffrir un être capable de
sensations capable de souffrance de le
faire souffrir inutilement mais le fait
est que le droit reste une notion
humaine et là ça va nous amener je pense
sur la question du spécisme c'est à dire
que rappelle toi on en avait parlé dans
notre débat sur la chaîne de pavés
gagnent juste avait dit par définition
le droit ne s'applique qu'à ceux qui
sont capables de comprendre de concevoir
la notion de droit pourquoi est ce que
par exemple l' esclavage est une
injustice parce que l' esclavage a
touché des personnes capables de se
représenter la notion de dignité capable
de se représenter
la notion d'égalité et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya eu ce qu'on a appelé la
controverse de valladolid
qui était finalement une espèce de
réflexion sur le fait de savoir si les
esclaves étaient oui ou non des êtres
humains
ça nous paraît complètement délirant
aujourd'hui certes
par contre il ya quelque chose qui nous
paraîtra pas délirant c'est le fait que
on a voulu se poser la question qui est
la bonne question est ce que ce sont des
êtres humains parce que si la réponse
est oui ça implique qu'on ne puisse plus
les traités comme des animaux justement
et c'est ça en fait il fait toute la
différence
parce que considéré que l'autre a des
droits
c'est considérer que l'autre a les mêmes
aptitudes que nous qu'il a les mêmes
capacités que nous en tant qu'humain
encore une fois et c'est pas pareil de
de maltraiter un être humain que de
maltraité un animal parce que l'être
humain il est capable d'avoir conscience
qu'il est utilisé comme un objet et
c'est très différent
je sais pas si tu me rejoindra là dessus
mais en tout cas j'avais vraiment envie
de faire cette précision avant de passer
à la suite parce que vraiment j'insiste
là dessus
la notion de droit me paraît être une
notion quand même qui a du sens le fait
de l'appliquer à des animaux me paraît
être un abus de langage et considérer
qu'il y aurait finalement une sorte de
voile à 2 d'égalité entre tous les êtres
vivants en tout cas entre tous les êtres
animaux c'est oublier le critère de la
conscience et de la dignité qui sont des
critères très important selon moi ouais
alors pour pour le pour ce que tu as dit
à la fin pour le l'égalité non enfin
nous moi je milite mais bien sûr l'idéal
je suis pas le seul avec les positions
on milite pour une égalité
de considération est puni gay mais pas
une égalité de traitement
c'est à dire qu'effectivement justement
comme dit peter singer par exemple
justement moment donné il parle pendant
des droits entre les hommes et les
femmes
il n'y aurait aucun sens par exemple
d'aller militer pour que les hommes et
le droit d'avorter par exemple parce que
par définition les hommes ne peuvent pas
avorter tu vois et donc on a un peu ce
même concept avec les animaux non
humains c'est à dire on n'est pas là
pour leur donner des droits équivalents
aux êtres humains dans le sens va pas
redonner un droit de voter l'ordre on
leur donne le droit de conduire une
voiture et cetera et cetera ça n'aurait
aucun sens ce qu'on veut c'est leur
donner des droits comme gîte à l'heure
des ligues des droits fondamentaux qui
viendrait de libertés fondamentales et
comme j'expliquais thaler donc de ne pas
être tués et considère comme des
marchandises etc etc
maintenant je comprends en fait ce que
tu veux dire j'ai l'impression que ce
que tu dis c'est une sorte on parle un
peu de respect de contrat social ou en
fait il ya ce côté être capable de
répliquer en fait de deux répliques et
justement ce concept de droit en gros
dire cité située tout montre si tu
montres un comportement moral envers moi
je devrais être capable de te rendre la
pareille à un petit peu ce côté là en
fait la capacité à rendre la pareille et
à comprendre justement le concept de
droit je comprends ce que tu veux dire
maintenant pour moi c'est le concept de
drogue à s'appliquer non pas
nécessairement à des individus qui sont
capables de comprendre ce concept
d'ailleurs je pourrais je veux pas je
veux c'est pas que je vais te citer du
peter singer etc etc mais là ça me
semble si une chose qu'il dit je peux
citer le cas du cas marginal que tu dois
j'imagine connaître où il dit justement
que c'était parce que c'est un peu le
même concept avec l'intelligence de dire
c'est pas parce que on est capable de
répliquer on est capable d'être
intelligent ou d'être aimable de
répliquer cette chose là que ça rompt ce
que ça inclut lundi dans un contenant
matière de considérations morales et par
exemple quelqu'un qui est sévèrement
handicapé mental
incapable par exemple de comprendre
cette notion de droit et de justement
d'être capable par l'antre de voter etc
etc
il ya toutes ces choses là et c'est pas
parce que justement un être humain par
exemple n'a pas ses capacités cognitives
à ce niveau là qui ne doit pas par
exemple être dépourvu de droit et cetera
et cetera et cetera
alors c'est là où justement je vois de
la part de peter singer ici une commande
pour appeler ça j'ai pas dire un
sophisme parce que ce serait l'accusé de
vouloir nous tromper mais j'y vois une
erreur de raisonnement c'est à dire que
prendre le cas particulier pour
justifier la règle c'est une démarche
intellectuelle qui n'est pas viable
parce que c'est comme si je te disais
par exemple qu'il y a plus de points
communs entre un européen du sud est un
africain du nord contre 1 européen du
sud et un européen du nord pour te dire
que les continents n'existe pas on se
dirait mais non ça marche pas comme ça
sais tu vois se le dire c'est une c'est
une démarche argumentatif qui repose
déjà sur la volonté de dire que les que
les frontières n'existent pas entre les
espèces ou entre les individus
mais on peut pas raisonner comme ça
parce que ça porte un nom ça s'appelle
s'appelle la déviation statistiques si
tu crées des ensembles et tu t'aperçois
que les extrémités des ensembles sont
plus proches entre eux que les deux
opposés du même ensemble mais évidemment
mais ça c'est c'est presque c'est un
truisme c'est une évidence
on est bien d'accord mais le cas de
langue de l'être humain handicapées il
est handicapé mais n'empêche qu'il
appartient à un groupe d'individus qui
sont les êtres humains qui en tant que
groupe possède la conscience et qui fait
qu' évidemment on va pas exclure
quelqu'un qui aurait une altération de
sa conscience de ce champ humain on est
bien d'accord
simplement c'est de dire que si on
n'utilise que ce genre d'exemple
eh ben on va se dire finalement il n'y a
pas de frontières il ya de frontières
entre rien et rien c'est parce que je
viens on va dire une vaste consciente à
plus de conscience qu'un humain
inconscient certes mais je vais te dire
un chêne conscient a plus
de conscience qu'une vache inconsciente
et ainsi de suite tu comprends ce que je
veux dire c'est pas viable et pour
construire une argumentation
après je pense que je ne sais pas
c'est peut-être un des gros
désapprouvent à avoir mais moi je
considère quand il dit ça qui laissait
juste de montrer en fait une espèce de
contradiction logique dans
l'argumentaire qui est par exemple de
dire si vraiment ton critères ton
critères un petit peu je dirais
nécessaire ou en tout cas le plus
important pour toi d'évaluation de
morale de valeurs morales d'un individu
c'est les capacités cognitives ou en
tout cas un niveau un certain niveau de
capacités cognitives
si on te démontre ce cas marginal et que
tu dis non je veux pas alors c'est à
dire que c'est pas ne s'est pas vu soit
c'est pas ce qui t'a là soit tu te
trompes soit c'est ce qui t'a l'a ajouté
à d'autres critères tu vois ce que je
veux dire mais gros c'est dire si si
vraiment pour toi le cap les capacités
les capacités cognitives un tel point
pour revenir à l'exemple qu'on avait
elle la conception du droit et la
capacité à répliquer justement certains
comportements dans notre société
si vraiment ces salles critères et que
tu es que tu me donnes malgré tout une
valeur morale à cette personne qui est
qu'il ya des capacités cognitives
inférieur à la moyenne en tout cas
inférieur à signer un tel niveau
c'est que ce n'est pas vraiment ce
critère là peut-être qu'ils jouent mais
il y aura forcément d'autres ça peut pas
être ce qu était effectivement on en
revient finalement comme tu dis est
alors au spécisme qui est en fait
justement c'est c'est de dire n'importe
quel appareil importe quel individu
finalement qui appartient à un groupe x
qui ici va être le groupe de l'espèce
humaine a nécessairement une valeur
morale parce qu'il appartient à ceux à
ce groupe là tu vois c'est eux et donc
effectivement on en vient forcément
c'est tous les chemins mènent aux
spécisme c'est parfait parce que
justement c'est très bien c'est très
bien amenée dans le sens où ça va me
permets de te poser une question que je
pense vraiment fondamental dans notre
désaccord qui est de dire on choisit un
critère pour savoir comment on va se
comporter vis-à-vis d'une espèce ou
vis-à-vis d'un groupe vis-à-vis d'un
individu ok
on a coutume d'utiliser le critère de la
conscience alors ça demanderait défini
évidemment ce serait un petit peu long
peut-être dans le cas de notre débat
mais conscience plus exactement de la
conscience de soi puisque l'être humain
il se définit surtout par sa conscience
de soi en tout cas à partir d'un certain
âge
et là encore on pourrait en discuter les
vegan considère que ce critère de la
conscience de soi n'est pas pertinent
pour faire une différence de traitement
vis-à-vis des animaux et à ce critère il
lui préfère le critère de l'ascension ce
qui est la capacité à avoir une
un ressenti une expérience subjective de
son existence
est ce que tu veux le définir un peu
plus précisément alors il me semble que
la définition littéralement de
l'assomption il me semble que c'est la
capacité à ressentir à percevoir et à
expérimenter la vie de manière
subjective
voilà et comme que ta définition
officielle de fonctions voilà et donc
l'ascension ce n'est pas la sensibilité
au sens littéral qui est la capacité à
éprouver des sensations d'accord qu'est
ce que tu entends par sensations parce
que la sentience inclut la sentence
inclut la saison ailleurs le plaisir etc
elle inclut les sensations mais par
contre elle ne se limite pas ne se
réduit pas aux sensations c'est à dire
dans la hiérarchie on va dire cognitives
il y aura les sensations d'abord les
sentiments et les émotions ensuite
et puis ce qu'on appellera la conscience
ou la conscience de soi pour être plus
précis qui est une rapport à soi un peu
plus un peu plus abstraite un peu plus
spirituelle pourrait-on dire et on a
coutume de dire que je partage
d'ailleurs cette conception historique
que l'être humain
c'est un être doué de la conscience de
soi parce qu'il est capable de se
représenter son existence dans le temps
et de manière d corpore comme disait
heidegger l'être humain est un être vers
la mort c'est annette qui a conscience
qu'un jour ou l'autre il va mourir
il n'a pas besoin si tu veux d'être
confronté à une situation mortellement
dangereuses pour savoir qu'un jour il va
mourir et ça à ma connaissance en tout
cas ça n'existe pas chez les animaux en
tous cas chez la plupart des
immo c'est pas quelque chose de
observable mais ma question c'est
pourquoi le critère de l'ascension
devrait-il être le bon critère
pourquoi pas le critère de la sensation
directement ou pourquoi pas le critère
de ce qu'on appelle la proprioception
qui est la capacité de se représenter
les différentes parties de notre corps
et qu'on trouve chez les végétaux par
exemple les végétaux peuvent subir des
stress ils peuvent adopter des
comportements par rapport à leur
environnement
et pourtant invega ne va pas les inclure
dans bad dans le champ des individus
qu'il faut respecter et dont il faut
maximiser le bien-être pourquoi ce choix
de l'ascension alors pourquoi ce choix
de la sentience tout simplement parce
que par définition un individu ne peut
souffrir on éprouve du plaisir que s'il
n'est sanction donc a priori dans la
mesure où une plante ou un caillou ou je
ne sais pas un téléphone n'est pas
champion quand même un téléphone répond
à des stimuli un téléphone est capable
d'adopter des comportements selon son
environnement par exemple selon la
luminosité etc etc
il n'est pas son option et donc il n'a
pas de valeur morale que j'ai on ne peut
pas l'inclure enfin on peut l'inclure
selon les critères mais dans lequel tu
as douanes ayant pas le qatar de 100 de
chances papa de l'inclure dans sa sphère
de considérations morales et donc
pourquoi un animal non humains les
animaux les animaux donc tout nu mince
en tuant peuvent donc souffrir et
expérimenter la vie de merde subjective
ils peuvent ressentir du plaisir ils ont
donc on peut donc leur faut donc leur
attribuer la notion de bien-être et la
notion de mal-être souffrance plaisir
etc etc et donc s'étaler et donc ces
animaux ont nécessairement des intérêts
à partir du moment où tu peux ressentir
du plaisir ressenti la douleur tu as
nécessairement l'intérêt d'aller plutôt
l'art du plaisir et d'éviter la douleur
contre un flic quand quand elles étaient
infligés
on va évidemment très facilement sur la
d animaux chez soi on avoue même quand
on voit des vidéos temps importe peu
importe des pratiques complet infligés
aux animaux
on voit très bien qu'un chien sur le
frappe
bye bye 6 et s'enfuir cet art etc et on
voit très bien ancien canton quand on
s'apprête à le faire sortir
on voit qu'il jubile donc voila c est qu
ont des intérêts et donc en vertu du
fait qu'ils sont capables de ressentir
justement des souffrances et du plaisir
c'est cette scéne au sérieux en fait qui
font d'eux des justement des patients
n'auront qu'à le fait que l'on puisse
les inclure dans notre sphère de
considérations morales ce qui n'est pas
le cas de tout objet qui ne peut pas
ressentir ce micro n'étant pas sanction
il y est incapable d'avoir des intérêts
propres
donc si je lui met un coup à la rigueur
savall ça va ça va la vie mais mon
matériel moi ça ma mère a savamment bt
mais pour le micro par définition
n'ayant pas d'intérêt il ne peut pas
ressentir de souffrent des plaisirs donc
pas de l'unc l'ambassade de
considérations morales est ce que c'est
ouais c'est clair et c'est très clair
bah écoutes je fais et je vais continuer
du kwatt à te porter la contradiction
parce que je vois quelque chose dans ce
que tu dis
dans le discours général sur
l'antispécisme qui me pose problème
c'est à dire le premier truc qui me pose
problème c'est le sait la volonté
d'ériger un critère qui est le critère
de la science comme si c'était ce
critère là qui devait être pris en
compte et pas un autre
je maintiens que le critère de la
sensibilité au sens de la sensorialité
le fait de ressentir des choses que ce
soit la douleur ou le plaisir tant qu'on
départ à la place d'une plante on peut
pas savoir si la plante souffre ou pas
en revanche ce que je vois c'est l'idée
que l'antispécisme à l'air quand même
deux plaqués sur le règne animal des
conceptions humaine c'est-à-dire une
définition humaine de ce qu'est la
souffrance quand tu va couper la tige
d'une fleur lafleur ne va pas crier
est ce que ça veut dire pour autant
qu'elle ne souffre pas en tant que
fleurs tu vois ce que je veux dire
et de la même façon on voit un animal
crié on se dit ils crient alors qu'on
égorge
il doit souffrir certes sans doute
moi c'est ce que je pense il doit
souffrir mais non il n'empêche que ça
reste vraiment de telles que j'ai cru
que j'allais me faire une des cartes non
non non non mais on pourrait parler des
cartes et des animaux machine parce
qu'en réalité c'est un concept qui est
mal compris chez descartes animaux
machine ça veut simplement dire qu'il se
comporte de manière mécanique que
nombreux et non pas liberté n'ont pas
libre arbitre c'est ça qu'il voulait
dire en réalité
mais ce que le verset que je vois de
l'anthropomorphisme paradoxalement dans
l'antispécisme c'est à dire une
conception et définition de la
souffrance qui correspond à notre propre
souffrance à notre propre manière
d'exprimer la souffrance donc quand on
va souffrir
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va faire la
démarche on va crier il comme on va
retrouver ça chez des animaux
on va dire il souffre la preuve vous
voyez il souffre puisqu'ils font comme
nous mais la plante elle elle peut très
bien souffrir en tant que plante sans
même qu'on ait une idée de ce que de ce
que représente pour elle cette
souffrance mais comme elle ne se
manifeste pas par des signes extérieurs
qui sont les nôtres on va partir du
principe qu'elle n'est pas sans science
et donc que finalement elle ne rentre
pas dans la sphère de considération des
intérêts j'y vois un entrepreneur fils
mais j'y vois même une forme d'injustice
mais en utilisant vers les plantes se
dire ben si on suit la logique
en réalité c'est à dire que moi j'adore
pas dans cette logique là et j'aurai
l'occasion d'exposer ma logique un peu
plus tard un accord mais sophie la
logique j'estime que l'exclusion des
végétaux de sept services faire de
considérations me paraît reposer sur des
bases très fragile alors pour le long on
entre forcément dans un domaine
scientifique qui s'appelle l'éthologie
par exemple ou al'inverse l'étude des
végétaux les plus tôt n'ont pas de nos
secteurs qui sont ce qu'ils sont qui
sont les qui est le système en fait qui
permet de ressentir la douleur donc a
priori à moins qu'une manque la science
ne permet de trancher abandonné 10
les végétaux en ressentent
de la souffrance ça me semble ça me
semble très très très très très très
risqué de dire que les animaux
qu'aujourd'hui les plantes sauf
ressentent à souffrance ou ressentent la
douleur il ya que la science qui peut
dire ça et en ce qui concerne en tout
cas les animaux
qu'est ce qui pousse alors on peut
effectivement jouer une carte sceptiques
en disant peut-être que les animaux qui
etc etc c'est pas forcément de la
douleur nous fait anthropomorphisme nous
comme on crie quand on a mal peut-être
que oeil quand ils ont mal il crée
également enfin peut-être qu'il crie
alors qu'ils n'ont pas mal et c'est
maintenant
y a des il ya quand même des
scientifiques qui ont qui ont tranché là
dessus depuis un moment quand justement
prouvé grâce à l'éthologie que les
animaux ressentent est réellement la
souffrance et d'ailleurs il ya eu le
sens d'une déclaration justement je
crois que c'était en 2012 il me sembla
déclaration alors j'ai peut-être dire
une bêtise mais je crois que c'est à
cambridge ou d'ennemis d'éminents
vraiment d éminents scientifiques
experts en neurosciences et cetera et
cetera étrangers sur la question après
après des études et des années passées à
ajustement étudier la question et ont
dit les animaux souffrent ils ressentent
la douleur ils ressentent des émotions
les expérimente la lumière subjective et
que c'est avec cette saison dont ils ont
vraiment voilà ils ont vraiment trancher
sur cette question a donc a priori
anthropomorphisme l'anthropomorphisme le
fait est que les animaux souffrent de la
même manière que nous on peut s'offrir
sa si les scientifiques ils le disent
maintenant on peut jouer effectivement
de 15,4 sceptique mais ça me paraît
quand même assez assez je sais pas si
pire de mauvaise foi mais en tout cas ça
me semble un argument difficile à tenir
bah c'est simplement qu'on rentre
bâtiments souvent très bien parce que
c'est vraiment pas l'aspect de
l'argument sur lequel je me polarise ray
ce serait plutôt l'autre versant qui est
de dire à quel moment s'arrête cette
notion de souffrance et le fait de
considérer qu'elle s'arrête à la
frontière du végétal me paraît pour le
coup n'ont pas de mauvaise foi mais en
tout cas très imprudente
parce que si on rattache la souffrance à
ce qu'on va appeler un système nerveux
je le dis vite parce que j'ai pas
beaucoup de notions de biologie mais je
comprends l'idée et si ce système
nerveux
effectivement on ne retrouve pas chez
les végétaux on va en déduire que les
végétaux ne souffre pas mais on est
toujours dans une conception de la
souffrance qui repose sur le critère du
système nerveux
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant que la
notion de souffrance se limite à ça dans
l'absolu c'est ça que je veux dire et je
suis pas en train de dire que du coup il
ne faut plus tuer les végétaux se
nourrir des végétaux et ainsi de suite
je dis simplement que c'est la question
du critère moi qui me pose problème
c'est à dire que par définition un
critère est toujours arbitraire par
définition on choisit ce qu'on va
utiliser pour faire une séparation entre
deux choses on a choisi historiquement
le critère de la conscience de soi pour
dire il ya les êtres humains qui sont
conscients de même et il ya les autres
qu'on peut utiliser
je schématise mais en gros c'est l'idée
est un moment donné le véganisme est
arrivé pour dire on va plus utiliser le
critère de la conscience on va écrire
utiliser le critère de l'ascension et à
partir de là tout ce qui est exclu de
l'ascension on va le considérait comme
non digne d'intérêt
je dis que simplement c'est un choix
tout aussi arbitraire que celui de la
conscience et que je ne vois pas de
raisons philosophie de se référer à ce
critère là plutôt qu'aller aux critères
que ce soit la conscience de soi où que
ce soit plus justement au bas de
l'échelle le simple critère de la
sensation alors je vais te répondre à ça
mais j'ai d'abord répondre à ce que tu
m'as 18 avant on est sûr soit tu croit à
la science étudient effectivement les
animaux sont sentions oui et tu dis que
les admis que les que l'époque ne
souffre pas site il écoute la science
est ce que la science dit ou alors tu
peux te dire que tu peux ne pas écouter
la science est à dire les plantes il y a
une chance qu'elle soit capable de
s'ouvrir et de se ressentir la douleur
et dans ce cas là bas le fait est que
les animaux d'élevage
en tous les cas mange des plantes et
nous ensuite on mange des animaux
d'élevage est en vérité les animaux
d'élevage mange plus de plantes mange
plus de calories en pente que nous ne
mangeons de calories en plante donc a
priori même si tu même si tu considérais
qu'il végète au étaient nos victimes
tu ferais moins de victimes végétale en
mangeant des italiens finalement qu'on
mangera des années qu'ils mangent plus
adhérente coup manger les animaux et que
tu manges des plantes par procuration
est bien évident que les vies donc si un
jour si un jour la science nous apprend
que les végétaux souffrent forcément ça
sera ça sera un retentissement énorme
il y en a vraiment rien contre mais
justement je le comprends il ya des
comportements chez les végétaux en tout
cas qui semble a indiqué et et encore
une fois je n'ai pas envie de me faire
le porte à porte étendard de la
condition de j'étale parce que c'est pas
du tout mon rôle il est aussi très élevé
le ton pourquoi pas mais il y aurait des
indicateurs qu'on pourrait mettre en
comparaison avec les les critères
humains et animaux de la souffrance et
se rendre compte qu'en fait ça
correspond c'est à dire moi je tenais ma
conception personnelle de la souffrance
mais c'est très personnel et limite j'ai
envie de dire ça n'a pas aidé argument
c'est juste pour préciser de ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est que pour moi la
souffrance c'est un message d alerte
c'est une information qui est envoyé
dans un individu pour lui signaler un
danger parce que je pense que les êtres
vivants par définition sont programmés
pour la survie pour persévérer dans leur
être comme dirait spinoza et que nous la
souffrance on va là on va là on va
l'expérimenter
d'un certain point de vue d'accords donc
on va mettre la main sur le feu et la
souffrance de la brûlure va nous dire
que c'est dangereux et que ne faut pas
s'amuser à ça pour animer un animal ce
sera ce sera autre chose
et puis pour un végétal le végétal reste
un être vivant et donc le signal qu'il
va recevoir au moment où sa vie est mise
en danger n'est certainement pas la même
chose que la souffrance que nous on
éprouve mais c'est un message qui à son
échelle de végétal correspond à ce que
nous on ressent à notre échelle humaine
et animale
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on
est toujours dans une relation
finalement de préférence de son propre
critères en quelque sorte
et moi ce que je reproche aux véganisme
sur ce plan là c'est d'aller chercher
chez l'animal le critère dont il est
également pourvu en tant qu'être humain
c'est-à-dire de faire de la projection
sur l'animal en se disant les animaux
sont nos égos et finalement de les
considérer comme nos égaux à partir d'un
critère qui est d'abord un critère
humain alors je vais lever tôt du temps
prenez dessus quand tu quand tu danses
âge est désolé mais non juste pour le
côté d'égalité encore une fois comme je
dis c'est pas on n'est pas les hommes
les animaux non humains ici tous les
animaux nimani cie les êtres humains ici
l'idée de il est en fait l'idée c'est de
dire tout simplement
on n'est pas obligés de se mettre au
même niveau de considération morale que
les autres animaux
si je te dire ne pas mettre les autres
animaux un tel degré de considérations
morales tellement bas finalement qu' on
peut se permettre justement de leur
faire subir ce qu'on en fait subir tu
vois c'est patent de dire que nous on
est là et eux ils sont là où même le
dessus c'est de dire qu'ils sont pas
assez bas dans la course dans la sphère
de considérations morales pour les
traiter comme on les traite c'est à dire
les exploiter les tuer etc etc
par millions par milliards maintenant le
je vois que certains prix mais que le
critère de la sentience et donc je vais
essayer de jouer essayer d'être le plus
le plus le plus clair par rapport à ce
critère là le quota l'ascension j'ai
commencé les fêtes de dire que comme
nous les animaux non humains souffrent
donc en fait c'est finalement c'est
jamais que le vélib s'est jamais que
prendre en compte une vérité très simple
c'est que faire souffrir un intrus un
être humain est aussi préjudiciable dans
sa propre expérience subjective
je veux faire souffrir un animal non
humain dans sa propre expérience
subjective
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est à dire
que la raison il me semble que par
définition la raison pour laquelle on ne
fait pas de mal aux êtres humains c'est
parce que leur faire du mal
c'est leur infliger des souffrances et
donc c'est la même chose pour les
animaux non humains c'est exactement la
même chose des cons on leur fait pas de
mal parce qu'on ne veut pas leur
infliger de souffrance si les êtres
humains n'étaient pas eux-mêmes pourvu
de 100 de chance il serait impossible
par définition de leur faire du mal
puisqu'il serait incapable de ressentir
de la souffrance ni déni de ressentir du
pied
etc etc ou en fait c'est juste prendre
ce critère-là de considérations morales
des êtres humains et de l'appliquer aux
animaux non humains parce que eux aussi
sont capables de ressentir la souffrance
eux aussi sont capables de ressentir du
plaisir et c'est donc c'est prendre les
intérêts des animaux non humains dans la
manière qu'on prend en compte les
intérêts des êtres humains parce que ça
te semble claire waysand intérieur bien
sûr et c'est loin d'être claires non
mais c'est bien parce que si on devait
réagir à tout à chacun
chaque détail sur lequel on n'est pas
totalement d'accord c'est sûr qu'on
passerait notre notre débat entier à se
reprendre mais je comprends exactement
ce que tu dis hein et c'est très clair
dans sa formulation et c'est d'autant
mieux que d'ailleurs que ça nous amène à
une question que j'avais envie de te
poser que j'ai déjà un petit peu abordé
tout à l'heure j'aimerais qu'on s'y
concentre un peu plus c'est à dire un
militant des gan a priori il a à coeur
de faire en sorte que les animaux ne
souffre pas ou en tout cas qu'il souffre
le moins possible et on pourra parler
d'ailleurs de de l'utilitarisme
minimiser les souffrances mais également
de faire en sorte que les animaux ne
soient pas exploitées que ce soit pour
se nourrir ou pour s'habiller ou pour
d'autres choses bon la question j'avais
te poser c'est est ce que finalement
dans certains cas il n'y a pas une
contradiction entre toutes ces exigences
parce que vouloir limiter la souffrance
animale
c'est pas la même chose que de vouloir
empêcher la mise à mort des animaux
je te dire pourquoi parce que moi je
suis pour qu'on minimise la souffrance
animale par exemple alors je ne suis pas
un expert dans ce domaine
j'ai cru comprendre que le mouvement
qu'on appelle le web charisme avait
vocation justement à minimiser la
souffrance des animaux tout en acceptant
le principe de leur exploitation
moi je serais plutôt de ce côté là si je
devais me définir même si j'aime pas me
définir parce que se définir c'est se
donner des limites
donc voilà mais je serais plutôt dans
cette optique là c'est à dire on n'a pas
ce faire souffrir inutilement mais par
contre mettre à mort un animal
n'implique pas forcément de le faire
souffrir et c'est là où je me dis
finalement est ce qu'il ya un critère
qui l'emportent sur l'autre parce que si
moi par exemple j'ai envie de dire je me
nourris de viande mais je ne veux pas
que ma cliente souffre pour un vegan
belge
je ne suis pas dans le bien mais
pourtant je suis contre la souffrance
animale
donc est-ce que d'une certaine manière
il n'y a pas une tension une
contradiction entre vouloir minimiser la
souffrance et d'un autre côté vouloir
purement et simplement abolir toute
forme d'exploitation
alors pour reprendre ton exemple
effectivement on peut tuer un animal
sans faire souffrir
c'est également le cas pour des êtres
pour des êtres humains à dire qu'on peut
tuer un être humain sans faire souffrir
ce soit pour des raisons comme
l'euthanasie par exemple en fin de vie
ou dans le cas d'un coma ou la personne
ne rêvez pas mais par définition un
tueur en série peut tuer ses victimes
sans les faire souffrir
je pense que tu seras aussi dago aussi
bien sur cet exemple là d'accord avec
moi de dire que ça n'empêche pas que
c'est quelque chose de large pour lequel
tu serais content ça j'ai mal je
condamne et justement alors je vais
tester poursuivre bien sûr mais c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est de dire pourquoi
j'estimerais que c'est condamnable pour
un être humain et pas forcément pour un
animal d'accord moi c'est ça que j'ai en
tête comme ça je suis transparent avec
toi donc je te laisse continuer à
développer ta réponse
mais pour moi on est justement dans deux
cas très différents et donc et donc
justement pour la même raison que pour
la même raison que je pourrais pas je
n'accepterai pas que l'on puisse tuer
des êtres humains ou même les exploiter
de manière éthique
je considère qu'il n'est pas morale de
faire la même d'infliger justement le
même là même la même souffrance ou de
repos des mêmes pratiques en va des
années envers des animaux non humains
c'est aussi simple que ça en fait tu
vois c'est c'est pal c'est pas le ton le
veau côté effectivement il n'ya pas que
côté exploitation comme tu dis a
effectivement le côté mise à mort
évidemment que nous les vegans les
antispécistes les animalistes etc
on se bat contre la mise à mort de
l'animal et et voilà parce que mettre à
mort un animal de manière en tout cas
évidemment prémédité volontaires etc etc
et programme est d'ailleurs puisque les
animaux les animaux par définition dans
les élevages sont leur mort est
programmée dès leur naissance
c'est quelque chose qui ne peut être
moralement justifiée dans la mesure où
ces animaux ont un intérêt à vivre tout
comme nous avons un intérêt à vivre et
c'est d'autant plus injustifiable que
comme je le disais il n'y a pas de
notion de nécessité là dedans c'est pas
nécessaire de le faire
donc à partir du moment où c'est pas
nécessaire de le faire on ne peut
qu'arriver à des conclusions comme pas
pourquoi on le fait parce que pour un
plaisir gustatif par exemple ou parce
que c'est quelque chose qu'on fait
depuis toujours ou parce que les
carnivores dans la nette sur le fondouk
nous ça nous donne la justification
morale de fer etc etc etc mais toujours
si tu veux cette notion de nécessité qui
est très importante
justement dans la défense du droit des
animaux puisque effectivement si nous
étions des carnivores qui nous est
impossible de survivre sans les
consommer ces animaux ça serait bien
évidemment impossible de défendre la
position sur laquelle nous devrions nous
laisser morin
tu es ce que tu vois ce que je veux dire
je vois ce que je veux dire eh bah
écoute moi je vais je vais battre mes
cartes comme ça en moins ce sera encore
plus simple
c'est là que je considère qu'il ya une
différence vraiment fondamentale entre
tuer un être humain et tuer un animal
c'est que l'être humain
on lui attribue une qualité qui n'est
pas une qualité que la science pourra
démontrer qu'il n'est pas une qualité
physique au matériel c'est ce qu'on
appelle la dignité et la dignité c'est
une notion symbolique c'est une notion
abstraite et métaphysique et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que les utilitaristes
la récuse totalement cette notion parce
que pour eux elle ne repose sur rien de
tangible mais le fait est que et là
encore ça n'engage que moi
le fait est qu'il y a dans l'acte
d'éliminer un être humain quelque chose
de plus en termes symboliques en termes
métaphysique que le fait d'éliminer un
animal dont on va se nourrir
parce que dans le cas précisément de
l'être humain être non on va pas le
manger
l'être humain on les dit mines c'est à
dire qu'on nie son humanité et ont ni
son caractère sacré on nie sa dignité
donc on nie sa dimension métaphysique et
selon moi l'être humain se définit au
sein du règne animal par cette propriété
très spécifique qui est cette relation à
la sphère du métaphysique cette relation
à la mort à la transcendance et au sens
de son existence
évidemment d'apprendre vue purement
matérialiste nous sommes des êtres
humains et notre ville n'a pas plus de
sens que n'importe quel être vivant et
d'un point de vue scientifique
c'est pour ça que pour moi le critère de
la science n'est pas n'est pas suffisant
n'est pas valable
c'est que d'un point de vue scientifique
rien n'a de sens en réalité il n'ya que
des processus qui s'accomplissent
finalement moi il me semble que les
rapports humains sont fondés sur cette
idée qu'il existe quelque chose de plus
que le corps quelque chose de plus que
notre existence physique
c'est cette notion symbolique sacré et
métaphysique tu vois ce que je veux dire
et étant donné que l'animal on va le
manger ben on peut pas dire que quand on
tue un animal on est simplement dans la
forme qu'on écrivait tout à l'heure de
la cruauté ou de houe de la torture
tu vois ce que je veux dire mais par
contre tu es un être humain pour le
manger ça ça ne poserait beaucoup plus
de problèmes en réalité parce qu'il ya
en nous 7e 7 ce sentiment cette
intuition ou cette conviction qu'il y a
dans l'humain quelque chose de plus
qu'un corps vivant tu vois ce que je
veux dire et pour moi si on exclut la
notion de dignité humaine du champ de la
réflexion éthique
forcément on va en arriver à la
conclusion qu'une vie n'a pas plus de
valeur qu'une autre mais il me semble
que dans les faits ça ne marche pas
comme ça
est ce que c'est une question que je me
semble est opposée du coup est ce que
pour toi le plaisir gustatif que tu
ressens
en mangeant de la viande juste important
ce plaisir que la ville animal qui est
mort pour te fournir ce plaisir alors
c'est une excellente question je vais te
répondre la manière la plus honnête
possible c'est que moi quand je mange
une pièce de viande et ça peut paraître
ridicule mais je vais essayer de
l'explicité un petit peu j'en suis
reconnaît je suis reconnaissant envers
cet animal de me procurer ce qui lui
procure alors je sais très bien qu'on va
me dire oui mais ça c'est facile c'est
trop facile mais il n'empêche que c'est
vrai moi tu sais alors ma famille ne
vient pas du sud de la france mais il se
trouve que je suis n'est que j'ai grandi
dans le sud de la france et on a une
expression typique dans le sud de la
france qui est que quand on nous sert un
grand repas on dit je vais faire honneur
on va faire honneur au repas et pour
nous le repas c'est presque un moment
sacré et tu respectes ce que tu as dans
l'assiette tu es conscient de la chance
que tu as de pouvoir te nourrir de ce
que tu as dans ton assiette et si tu
veux mon là dessus j'ai une vision très
comment dire très à l'ancienne c'est à
dire que la notion de sacrifice animal
pour moi elle a un sens c'est à dire que
on prend une vie et on remercie cette
vie que l'on prend parce qu'elle vient
alimenter le cycle vital et là on peut
partir sur un débat presque
philosophique sur la question de la vie
c'est que la vie se nourrit de la mort
en réalité est que le cycle vital c'est
qu'il y à des individus kilmer qui meurt
pour laisser leur place à d'autres
individus qui vont naître
ensuite c'est le cycle naturel de la vie
et que on élimine au sens vital des
individus de la surface de la terre ne
me paraît pas incohérent avec cette
notion de cycle vital parce que nous
même quand nous allons mourir
nous allons nourrir la terre secteur qui
va donner des végétaux qui vont nourrir
les animaux dont l'homme d'à se nourrir
et on est là pour ça en réalité tu vois
ce que je veux dire moi ça ne me choque
pas si tu veux qu'on mette à mort un
animal pour le manger à partir du moment
où on a conscience qu'on a mis à mort un
animal animal veut dire animée c'est à
dire doué d'une âme et que cette pièce
de viande qui est sous nos yeux à
d'abord été un animal c'est à dire
quelque chose de vivant dont on profite
pour pouvoir perpétuer le cycle vital
voilà ok
alors je comprends ce que tu veux dire
c'est c'est un argument qu'on entend
c'est vrai alors pour moi le fait que la
mort c'est vrai existe on peut dire que
la mort fait partie du cycle de la vie
c'est vrai je vais pas nier
effectivement la mort est partout tout
le temps maintenant pour moi le fait que
la mort existe ne justifie pas qu'on l'a
convolent la vie d'individus à dire que
certes tous les êtres humains vont
mourir tous les animaux non humains vont
mourir
c'est une condition nécessaire de la vie
je ne pense pas que là si je ne pense
pas que cela soit une justification
morale suffisante pour aller tuer des
êtres vivants sous prétexte qu'ils vont
mourir
on peut se permettre de les tuer pour
moi c'est une c'est un argumentaire qui
est même
évidemment je sais que c'est pas juste
parce que je sais que c'est parce que tu
veux dire mais je trouve que c'est un
argumentaire très dangereux parce que
par définition extérieurement terre
n'importe qui peut tuer n'importe qui
voilà parce qu'on est tous destinés à
mourir de toute manière alors maintenant
reste maintenant quand tu dis
effectivement ce côté respecter je tue
un individu et mais je le respecte et je
suis trop coller à cette manière
reconnaissant voilà du plaisir qui me
procure et c'est tard et c'est la porte
pardon de la force qu'il m'apporte de la
force qui t'apporte là c'est pareil
c'est je trouve que c'est un
argumentaire qui était assez dangereux
parce que finalement
peut par définition avec un argument
comme celui ci tu es effectivement
n'importe qui ou n'importe quoi en
disant si je le mange et qu'il m'apporte
de la force là on peut dire que ça va
être par parent d un apport nutritionnel
ça veut dire que tu peux tu est
effectivement le n'importe qui peut
aller tuer je sais pas moi un chien un
chat je sais pas un éléphant une girafe
peu importe le manger et dire je te suis
reconnaissant de m'avoir de m'avoir
apporté ce ces protéines ou que sais-je
c'est d'ailleurs un argument pourrait
entendre de la part des êtres humains le
cannibalisme à exister dans notre dans
notre histoire il est possiblement
encore dit dans certaines tribus je ne
sais pas trop mais il a existé en tout
cas dans notre histoire
et justement il y avait ce côté on prend
l'avis de personne on les manque et il
ya ce côté respectueux et effectivement
et c'est donc moi je trouve que c'est un
argumentaire qui est assez dangereux et
et je le considère pas comme un
argumentaire suffisant pour justement
justifier le fait de mettre à mort des
individus sanctions voilà alors je
comprends que tu le peux tu le jugent
dangereux
simplement j'ai l'impression que tu en
mets le le comment dire
l'élément essentiel de cet argument qui
est que justement je ne considère pas
que la valeur de la vie d'un être humain
soit la même que la valeur de la vie
d'un animal si je considérais que cette
valeur était là même ce qui peut se
discuter mais ce qui n'est pas mon cas
on pourrait dire ah bah finalement si tu
acceptes de tuer des animaux pourtant
nourrir ça veut dire que tu acceptes
aussi de tuer des êtres humains donc
parce que justement
j'établis et j'assume une hiérarchie ni
hiérarchie des valeurs entre la vie d'un
être humain et la vie d'un animal pour
des raisons qu'on a un petit peu évoquée
je pourrais les développés qui est que
un être humain ayant conscience du sens
de son existence lui ôter son existence
n'a pas la même signification symbolique
côté l'existence à un être qui n'est pas
conscient de ce qu'est l'existence c'est
à dire
que ce que l'existant se définit par le
fait de savoir qu'on va mourir un jour
ou l'autre
tu vois ce que je veux dire donc ça n'a
pas la même valeur symbolique et quand
je dis que je suis reconnaissant en
l'animal et c'est qu'on soit bien
d'accord je suis pas en train de dire
que je suis pour une forme de l'abattage
systématique des animaux qui serait au
service des êtres humains
j'ai donné un exemple pour moi le chien
tu vois c'est une exploitation du loup
c'est à dire que je passe tu connais la
fable le loup le loup et le chien de la
fontaine qui technique que voilà le
chien il est bien gras il est bien
nourri
mais il a pas de liberté tu vois il a un
collier le loup il est maigre mais par
contre il est sauvage personne ne le
sont
ben moi j'ai plus si tu veux le
tempérament du nous c'est à dire que le
chien moi je suis pour son bien-être etc
mais finalement l'animal à l'état
sauvage il se pose pas vraiment la
question
il cherche à survivre c'est sa seule
préoccupation alors on va on va revenir
si tu si tu es d'accord
et quand tu auras répondu sur la
question du bien être animal parce que
ça me semble absolument fondamental
qu'on aborde cette question là pour moi
un animal dont je me nourris j'accepte
sa mise à mort passe récemment la valeur
de sa vie n'est pas la même que la
valeur d'un être humain
en revanche je suis contre le faire
souffrir parce que je pars du principe
comme toi je pense que la souffrance
d'un animal
elle est aussi importante et aussi
finalement comment prédire condamnable
elle est autant à rejeter à éviter que
la souffrance d'un être humain
1 qu'est ce que tu m'as dit juste avant
cette dernière phrase ne mettait pas je
n'accordais pas autant de valeur à la
vie d'un animal que la vie d'un être
humain pour des raisons liées à la
conscience à la concernant leur soin et
au sens de son existence dans le temps
qui me semble être le critère vraiment
important alors justement m'aviez posé
la question dans le monde en mon débat
précédent avec pas bien et c'est quand
tu m'avais justement demandé est ce que
pour moi les on en revient à ce que je
suis ce que je disais tout à l'heure
aussi est ce que les êtres humains et
les autres animaux ont une
sais tu comment tu avais posé la
question mais pour moi est ce qu'ils ont
la même valeur morale ou est-ce que des
animaux ont plus de valeur morale que
les intrusions et c'est avec sa faune
moi dans mon système de morale les êtres
humains ont plus de valeur morale que
les haines que les autres aux animaux ce
que je dis encore une fois c'est que les
autres animaux ne sont pas à un niveau
si bas que je me permettrai de les tuer
ou leur faire du mal
d'accord donc voilà c'est clair qu'on
peut on peu et beaucoup ses cadres de
beaucoup devaient gagner beaucoup
antispécistes dire que les années que
les êtres humains ont une valeur morale
supérieure à celle des autres animaux
notamment par pertinence avec le critère
de la sentience vu que les êtres humains
ont a priori un degré de sentir
supérieur à celui des autres animaux
donc à partir de là on peut
effectivement dire les êtres humains est
une valeur morale supérieure à celle des
autres animaux meskine ce n'est pas
suffisant pour me donner le droit de les
tuer les exploiter et cetera et cetera
c'est très clair et je tiens à noter et
on ne l'avait un petit peu parlé hors
antenne que tu n'es pas représentatifs
de la pensée ou même de la mentalité
vegan comme moi je ne suis pas
représentatif ou représentants de la
pensée anti vegan ou non vegan et je
pense que c'est important
la précision que tu viens de faire c'est
très important parce que moi j'ai
tendance à aa
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a chez les
vegans une tendance à dire tout se vaut
et les animaux non humains les animaux
humains et quel que soit finalement
l'espèce au sein du règne animal que
tout ça a la même valeur
toi tu me dis que dans ta conception
personnelle en tout cas ce n'est pas le
cas et la motion jazzy moi j'ai
directement moi je suis dans une à
partir du moment mon critère de
dévaluation morale c'est le sait la
sentience effectivement à partir de là
effectivement selon le degré de centre
sciences un animal va être capable de
d'expérimenter de manière subjective et
c'est des émotions de manière plus
importante plus intense et notamment
comme tu le disais c'est un petit
critères effectivement qui place l'être
humain au dessus des autres animaux
cette capacité par dante à faire des
projets
à savoir qu'il va mourir et c'est à
pouvoir vraiment être dans l'ambition et
c'est pouvoir se construire un futur se
forger un futur ça pour moi c'est
justement ce sont des choses qui font
que l'être humain peut avoir une valeur
morale supérieure à celle des autres
animaux néanmoins encore une fois ce
n'est pas né ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
un critère suffisant pour s'octroyer le
droit de vie ou de mort sur les autres
animaux je comprends je vais prendre un
exemple pour peut-être illustrer ma la
plus explicite pour nos auditeurs ce que
j'entends par la valeur de l'être humain
que je considérais supérieur comme celle
de l'animal parce que je sais que dit
comme ça formulée de manière aussi
brutale ça peut donner l'impression que
c'est quelque chose finalement de la
kiné qui n'est pas soutenue par des
arguments la mort d'un enfant humain
causera toujours plus de peine
y compris pour des personnes qui n'ont
pas de relations avec cet enfant qui ne
sont pas de sa famille causera toujours
plus de peine que la mort d'un vieillard
pourquoi parce qu'on considère que le
vieillard il a vécu et donc d'une
certaine manière c'est naturel qu'ils
finissent par mourir alors que l'enfant
on considère quelque chose qui ne va pas
qui n'est pas logique qui n'est pas
naturel c'est que l'enfant il avait
devant lui toute une vie à vivre
qui n'a pas vécu si on s'en tient à un
plan strictement physiques et
matérielles on a un être humain capable
de sang science et un autre qui meurent
mais dans la relation symbolique qu'on a
avec l'existence on a des raisons de
penser que c'est plus grave la mort d'un
enfant
on a des raisons d'être plus indignée
par la mort d'un enfant passeront pas ce
qu'on a en tête toute la vie qu'il
aurait pu avoir et qu'il n'a pas eue
et donc ça ne je pense que n'importe
quel vegan ne trouverait pas absurde
qu'on sacrifie un vieillard dans une
situation de choix de dilemme urgent
qu'on sacrifie un vieillard au profit
d'un enfant et bien les raisons pour
lesquelles j'accorde une une valeur
supérieure à la vie humaine
c'est exactement sont exactement les
mêmes raisons pour lesquelles j'accorde
plus de valeur à la vie d'un enfant
qu'est la vie d'un vieillard c'est parce
que tout ce qui est potentiellement à
vivre a de la valeur pour un être humain
je vois ce que dire c'est moi c'est cet
enfant c'est la promesse d'un d'un vécu
c'est la promesse de toute une série
d'expériences
voilà c'est très difficile à
conceptualiser parce qu'on
un peu de gens physiquement très bien
comprend très bien ce que tu veux dire
moi tout ce que je peux te répondre à ça
c'est effectivement en fait finalement
là ça c'est une chose sur laquelle on
est d'accord finalement et moi tout ce
que je peux dire ah ça c'est que j'ai
aucun problème c'est quelque chose qu'on
m'a dit javel à paris ça dans un débat
justement j'ai aucun problème avec le
fait que tu sois ou que n'importe qui
considère que l'être humain est une
valeur morale supérieure à celle d'un
autre animal ça me pose absolument aucun
problème
moi ce que j'ai simplement c'est tu peux
considérer que êtres humains ont une
valeur morale supérieure aux autres
animaux mais cela ne devrait pas
d'octroyer au droit de vie ou de mort
sur ces animaux là quoi tu vois c'est
que c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas une
différence
tél entre les êtres humains et les
autres animaux qui peut qui puise qui
puisse vraiment justifier un tel
comportement parce que je veux dire je
vois très bien et je pense que c'est
intéressant parce que notre situation
permet au sida de dessiner un peu mieux
les contours de notre pensée à chacun
donc c'est très intéressant
est-ce que tu serais encore encore chaud
pour continuer un petit peu parce que je
voudrais qu'on parle un peu de peter
singer et de l'utilitarisme masi oka
m'ont alors dit à ses valeurs comme un
problème montre que l'essence coteaux à
ce niveau là mais on en passe en ce
moment et je vais pas y aurait de toute
façon parce que le but c'est vraiment
con à un échange où on se comprenne l'un
à l'autre et puis les auditeurs seront
les seuls juges de toute façon peter
singer donc c'est un philosophe
australien contemporain qu'on appelle
également un éthicien c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui évoluent dans le champ de
la réflexion éthique et qui s'inscrit
dans le prolongement de l'utilitarisme
alors je vais faire un petit peu le
faire un peu le prof donc l'utilitarisme
c'est un mouvement philosophique qui est
apparu en europe on va dire
officiellement
1 au xviie siècle xviie xviiie siècle
est celui qui l'a le plus formalisées
c'est jeremy bentham suivi par john
stuart mill et le principe des
utilitariste c'est de considérer que le
seul critère d'évaluation moral d'un
acte c'est sa propension à produire plus
de plaisir que de souffrances donc on
rejoint ce critère du plaisir et la
souffrance ou en tout cas du bien-être 1
et delà de la douleur ou de la peine
partant de là peter singer va considérer
que de ce point de vue là tu es un
nouveau né ou tuer un animal mais
finalement ça peut se valoir
en réalité parce que dans son logiciel
la notion d'unité n'entre pas en ligne
de compte pour les utilitaristes la
notion de dignité finalement elle n'a
rien à faire là c'est une notion
métaphysique et abstraite les
utilitaristes sont des matérialistes
est-ce qu'on souffrait ce qu'on souffre
pas est-ce qu'on éprouve du plaisir ou
pas bien moi la question que j'aimerais
te poser c'est est-ce qu'être
antispécistes c'est se reconnaître dans
la philosophie de de peter singer et
sinon en quoi serait tu en désaccord
avec la pensée de peter singer
alors c'est un peu dur parce que
effectivement j'ai lu par exemple
libération animale
il ya des choses clairement et quel show
en désaccord et d'autres avec laquelle
sont d'accord c'est dur de dire comme ça
avec moi j'arrivais l'analyse avec
walter d accord pour qu on puisse
ensuite s'entendre sur sur ce à quoi tu
es d'accord
ben moi par exemple je vais t'en
désaccord sur mais pas sur des choses
auxquelles tu t'attends peut-être moi je
vais être en désaccord par exemple quand
il dit que qu'on peut justement il est
un peu cette même vision toi finalement
c'est de beaucoup de monde qui est de
dire faire souffrir un animal c'est mal
lu tu es sans qu'il ne souffre
aucunement ce n'est pas quelque chose
finalement de six immoral que ça puisque
l'animal n'a pas conscience de son futur
et que l'état et c'est donc moi je suis
en désaccord avec sa bulle et lui ça va
pas être ça va pas être un argument qui
qu'il défend moi je défends
effectivement qu'on ne peut pas les
faire souffrir mais qu'on ne doit pas
non plus y tuer et donc les priver de
leur futur gendre est d'accord avec lui
là dessus maintenant
peter singer
il a dit voilà il est effectivement il
est plus je demande dans ce qu'on
appelle le web faris du coup justement
c'est ça c'est la philosophie de singer
même ce quand bien même il est
antispécistes il considère qu
effectivement il faut il faut par
ailleurs en premier lieu diminue pas
souvent des animaux
les gens disent en général améliorer le
bien être animal moi je préfère dire
diminuer la souffrance pour des raisons
que je pourrai est expliquée oblige
évoque souvent mais mais voilà donc lui
il est effectivement plus dans cette
approche là moi je suis dans une
approche plutôt abolitionnistes qui a
vraiment de mettre fin vraiment d'abolir
l'exploitation animale
donc ça les principaux désaccords et
puis après c'est vrai qu'il fait parfois
des comparaisons certains et l'emploi
certains des arguments qui me semble
douteux notamment
justement il ya un argument alors je ne
sais plus quel c'est une espèce de cas
marginal mais modifié justement il me
semble avec le cas d'un enfant où je
sais plus comment il le formule mais
c'est quelque chose d'une cible une
somme jugée telle enquête
en désaccord avec ça mais je pourrais
peut être je pourrai plus vraiment de
préciser il a il ya une citation de
peter singer dans alors c'est une
citation d'un entretien bon j'ai
tendance à relativiser la valeur aussi
des affirmations faites dans un
entretien parce qu'on s'exprime de
manière plus spontanée
donc ce n'est pas forcément le reflet de
la pensée réelle mais dans un dans une
revue qui s'appelle la recherche qui a
été publié en octobre 2000 il a dit tu
es un nouveau-né n'est pas équivalent à
tuer une personne est dit un peu plus
loin on peut considérer que jusque là
alors je sais plus quelle qu'elle dure
il utilise mais quelques quelques
semaines ou quelques mois
on peut considérer que jusqu'à attend de
moi un nouveau-né n'est pas un être
humain et d'un point de vue rationnel
est purement matérialiste je comprends
cette idée celle que le nouveau-né
n'étant pas dotée de toutes les
capacités en termes de considération de
ses propres intérêts cana du ltte son
système finalement et cohérent et c'est
pour ça qu'il me disait je pense à juste
titre que tu trouvais que finalement je
n'ai pas si loin que ça de lui parce que
mon premier critère c'est celui tu sais
toujours c'est celui de la cohérence
et que dans son logiciel que je réfute
il est cohérent il part du principe que
comme il n'y a pas de notion dignité
battu à nouveau né tuer une personne
c'est pas pareil parce que quelque part
c'est l'être humain n'a pas de valeur en
soi quoi tu vois c'est sont ces fonds
présupposés morale c'est pas le lien et
c'est le sien donc c'est cohérent par
rapport à ça effectivement il ya ceux il
ya cette chose qui revient souvent dans
l'argumentation peter singer qui est de
10 m et de l'utilitarisme nador en
général il me semble qui est de dire que
la vie n'a pas de valeur morale
intrinsèque dire que la ville en
elle-même n'a pas de leur moral
c'est vraiment ça c'est vraiment c'est
justement cette santion cette capacité à
ressentir du plaisir
candy plaisir je précise quand même pour
pour les personnes qui nous écoutent ou
qui nous regardent quand on parle de
plaisir dans l'utilitarisme c'est on
parle de la notion du bonheur c'est pas
le plaisir du corps etc etc et aussi
l'épisode intellectuelle et ceara c'est
pas juste le plaisir trivial etc voilà
mais effectivement je suis un peu dans
le même cas là pour moi pour moi là
effectivement la vie en elle-même n'a
pas une valeur morale intrinsèque
ce qui pour masquer à la valeur morale
encore une fois c'est vraiment ce cette
capacité à ressentir la souffrance ou du
plaisir maintenant pour le cas dont tu
me parles
est-ce que tu saurais resituer le
contexte parce que je sais plus je serai
petit directement le contexte je
voudrais pas vraiment dire des bêtises
mais effectivement il me semble que
quand il dit ça c'est justement est en
fait il veut dire que dans son point de
vue à lui par exemple je me demande s'il
fait pas là d'ailleurs la comparaison
avec un cochon quand il dit tuer un
cochon ont tué un enfant en disant que
le cochon bain par exemple il à ilan
intelligence il me semble d'un enfant
l'équivalent d'après ce que dit la
science d'un enfant de 5 ans
intelligente des enfants 2,50 côté a les
capacités cognitives en est donc en
vertu du fait que l'enfant de je sais
pas quel âge
mais plus il est très jeune a des
capacités cognitives inférieure à celle
d'un cochon donc on devrait privilégier
la vie du cochon parce que il est
capable de il a une confiance et des
capacités cognitives supérieures à
l'enfant c'est pas un argument que je
tiens avant tout à ça c'était pas vrai
j'ai pas d'accord avec lui sur ce sur ce
point j'ai fait la recherche rapidement
la par mots clés 1
ce sur quoi je suis tombé c'est que il
estime peter singer que la souffrance
d'un chien la souffrance d'un cochon
tout ça et la balle qui vaut plus que
l'autre donc effectivement on pourrait
étendre sa également à l'être humain
donc je mettrai les liens mois dans la
description vers cet article que j'ai
cités mais moi j'ai une question à poser
guillaume parce que ça fait plusieurs
fois en fait que tu le que tu le dis
sans que je rebondisse dessus c'est
qu'est ce qui fait que toi tu n'accorde
pas la même valeur à la vie d'un être
humain qu'est la vie d'un animal
ben justement c'est moi ce que justement
c'est ce que je dis le niveau de 100 de
chance c'est à dire que pour moi il est
évident que un animal qui est à peine
capable de s'offrir dont la souffrance
peut atteindre je sais pas je veux pas
je veux pas faire de l'utilitarisme
justement un peu cliché mais si on veut
mettre des chiffres là dessus par
exemple un animal qui est capable de
ressentir
enfin points de souffrance aura moins de
valeurs morales en tout cas qu'un animal
qui est capable de ressentir 100 points
de souffrance ce que tu vois ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il ya vraiment il ya
vraiment fait 7 cette jauge de 100 de
chance qui pour moi doit définir le clip
de critères d'évaluation morale
notamment pour l'être humain qui est
capable justement donc en plus de la
sanch ans qui effectivement capable de
faire des projets etc
donc voilà il ya c'est vraiment ce c'est
vraiment cette jauge de santé sciences
qui qui selon qui le sont son niveau
influe sur le la considération morale
réellement d'individus quoi d'accord ça
m'évoque une question à laquelle j'ai
pas de réponse donc je serai pas là pour
pour te piégé là dessus c'est la
quantification de la souffrance tu le
sais en tant que sportif
le rapport à la souffrance varient
beaucoup d'un individu à l'autre et si
tu les soumet aux mêmes conditions deux
individus vont avoir un ressenti
totalement différent et ça ça pose le
problème de la mesure de la souffrance à
quel moment est ce qu'on peut dire que
quelqu'un souffre vraiment et jusqu'à
quel point on peut dire qu'il fait du
cinéma
tu sais comme quand un enfant tombe par
terre et puis que
mais me vois qu'on le regarde il se met
à pleurer en fait il sait pas trop ce
n'est pas tellement fait mal
donc il ya cette question-là du critère
de la mesure de la souffrance et
personnellement j'ai tendance à penser
que c'est quelque chose de très
difficile
c'est à dire que là où toi par exemple
tu vas recevoir un choc et tu va plutôt
bien encaissé quelqu'un d'autre va être
vraiment meurtri va ressentir une
souffrance que tu ne peux même pas
envisagées parce que la sensibilité
n'est pas la même parce que je veux dire
donc est ce que tu penses pas qu'il ya
dans ce dans ce critère même de
l'ascension ce problème épistémologique
c'est d'ailleurs ce problème de mesure
de la souffrance en elle-même alors ça
effectivement c'est une excellente
question je trouve que c'est une
excellente question
malheureusement je pense que finalement
il ya que par des données empiriques
qu'on peut répondre et notamment je
pense que c'est la neuroscience qui va
être capable si vraiment on veut être
capable de te donner une évaluation
précise du niveau de souffrance
ressentie ou du niveau de plaisir
ressenti
finalement je pense qu'il ya que la
neuroscience qui peut le dire via
probablement des neurotransmetteurs et
c'est hradecka le jeu quelle est la
technologie mais qui en étudiant le
cerveau et la façon dont le cerveau
réagit en temps réel à des stimuli et
ministre sous françois plaisir qui va
être capable de digérer
ben apparentés l'espèce pour sentir
autant de souffrances et qatar etc
après après on est forcément comme tout
finalement au lieu de se fier à nos sens
et notamment pour le coup la vue etc et
de d'être capable justement de
reconnaître la souffrance lorsqu'elle
est lorsqu'elle est présente à la fois
chez nos pères chez les êtres humains et
chez stradim en fait ce qui est facile
c'est qu'on a effectivement cette
tendance à réagir un peu toutes et tous
de la même manière alors savoir
finalement on en revient à une question
qui effectivement qui en philosophie qui
est assez présente qui est toujours
intéressante c'est de dire comment est
ce qu'on sait que lorsqu'une personne
souffre elle ressent la même chose que
nous comment on peut être comment est ce
qu'on peut avoir
enfin voilà on est on a tous un tour
propre à notre propre expérience
subjective mais comment sait-on que tout
le monde a la même expérience subjective
voilà c'est c'est celle des questions
qui sont hyper intéressante moi je peux
pas te répondre là-dessus effectivement
sauf te dire que il faut voir ça avec la
science des données empiriques et
capables de
voir comment leurs cerveaux répondre à
telle ou telle stimuli finalement c'est
la meilleure réponse que je pense que je
peux te donner 3 meuse ça marche est ce
qu'il y aurait des questions des points
qu'on n'a pas abordé ou qu'on aurait
trop peu abordé que tu vous sur lesquels
je voudrais qu'on revienne qu'on
approfondisse bas en moyenne juste sur
le spécisme en fête ou où j'aime bien
j'aime bien avoir proposé une expérience
de pensée
justement un peu qui peut pas là tout le
monde et qui est un peu geek c'est de
dire si tu considère par exemple que
l'espèce l'espèce est un critère morale
pertinent pour pour avoir s'octroyer le
droit de vie ou de mort sur d'autres
espèces par exemple ce qui est le cas a
priori de la plus du spécisme qui de
dire parce que nous sommes des êtres
humains nous sommes l'espèce humaine
donc en tant qu'espèce supérieur ou en
tout cas à doter de capacités que
n'existe pas ailleurs on n'est qu'un
peut s'octroyer droits des noirs
extérieur et autres animaux et quand tu
regarde par exemple tout bêtement un
film quand même comme avengers où tu
t'intéresses à marvel et que tu vois un
mec comme thanos qui débarque pour moi
on est un peu là dedans tu vois on est
un peu dans ce côté tarde à naître qui
arrive à naître un être sans trembler
des capacités cognitives au moins
équivalente à celle d'un être humain
ça va être la noce si tu considères
finalement que l'espèce est un critère
pertinent ou tout cas suffisant pour ce
troisième vide le droit de vie ou de
mort sur d'autres animaux finalement
tanoh ce qui arrive et qui dit si les
les êtres humains qui dit qui dit tu
sais pas qui voit un aspect site en face
de lui qui dit mec ou fille si tu
considères que parce que une espèce et à
des capacités cognitives supérieures
elle peut s'octroyer droit de mort il
peut claquer des doigts il n'est pas
immoral quand il claque des doigts parce
qu'effectivement il peut déjà bas moi
aussi je suis pessimiste
moi aussi je considère que mon espèce à
moi de thanos pas question espèces dans
marvel me dit voilà moi c'est mon jeu
c'est mon chum dans une autre espèce
juger des capacités cognitives au moins
équivalente à celle d'un être humain je
suis sanctions je suis capable de faire
des projets du futur etc etc
et donc si je claque des doigts tu peux
en tout cas et s'ils m'ont empêché mais
tu pourras pas dire que moi qui
extermine être l'humanité
c'est immoral parce que moi aussi je
suis spéciste et que moi si je considère
que mon espèce est un critère suffisant
pour infliger ça allait à l'humanité je
suis pas en train de poser la question à
toi personnellement mais tu vois c'est
désespérant de penser qu'ils sont
souvent d'ailleurs très philosophique
est bon la jeune un peu geek et cette
expérience là mais je trouve ça
intéressant de quoi se poser des
questions comme ça et de prendre des
arguments qui sont les nôtres
des critères qui sont les nôtres et
d'essayer de trouver des comme ça dépend
de penser qu'ils les remettre en cause
qui remettent en cause
ça va pas forcément nous convaincre sa
d'abord c'est sympa pas forcément de
convaincre mais c'est bien des fois de
se remettre en question de cette manière
là c'est très bien parce que moi j'ai
tendance justement à utiliser aussi des
fois des références très parlante pour
illustrer des concept philosophique
parce que c'est ça qui justement fait
qu'on va on va se sentir concerné par
par le propos donc c'est très bien que
ça va claquer dans la section
commentaires à mon avis je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de monde qui va répondre à
ça il ya des chances de toute façon ce
sera animé forcément parce que
l'intitulé même de notre vidéo va faire
que ça va ramener un petit peu des gens
qui aiment la polémique
donc ça on le sait de toute façon on est
tous les deux sur youtube
donc on est prêt à ça on l'a dit en
préambule on n'est pas susceptible donc
si vous voulez dire que charles est un
con ou que athlétique est un ignorant ou
ce que vous voulez ça nous ça nous
dérange pas parce que on est conscient
aussi des limites du format 1u ont fait
un débat sur youtube on est obligé aussi
d'aller à l'essentiel
donc il ya certaines choses qu'on aurait
pu nuancé qu'on n'a pas nuancé mais ça
fait partie du jeu c'est pas grave je
pense que nos auditeurs auront bien vu
qu'on est dans une démarche des changes
qu'on n'était pas d'accord sur tout loin
de là mais qu' on se l'est dit est que
chacun pourra ensuite prendre ce qui
l'intéresse et se positionner donc moi
j'invite tous mes abonnés toute ma
communauté
si ce débat les uns les un enthousiasme
et leur a plu d'aller sur ta chaîne
allait voir ce que tu proposes en terme
de
en terme de contenu tu as une chaîne qui
qui démarre et kiki qu'on commence à
enregistrer des bons scores
donc voilà je suis de collègues youtuber
j'ai envie de te dire bonne chance à toi
de toute façon est ce que tu voudrais
conclure cet entretien je te laisse vous
écoute le mot de la fin
j'ai trouvé cet entretien très bien j'ai
trouvé ça super intéressant c'est bien
de pouvoir parler avec quelqu'un qui n'a
pas peur de parler de morale et
d'éthique
je trouve ça je trouve ça très important
et je te remercie pour ça en tout cas je
trouve que je trouve ça c'est super de
bastille écoute moi en tout cas je
condamnerai clairement toute personne en
tout cas de ma communauté je suis passé
une communauté mais si jamais quelqu'un
qui viendrait qui viendraient attaqué
autre chose que les arguments battre
comment attaquer la personne c'est
quelque chose de tout simplement 2 nuls
2 d'inutile et quelque chose qu'il faut
bannières et pour moi justement
l'importance est toujours d'attaqué les
arguments jamais les personnes donc
voila c je trouve ça super intéressant
pareil moi pour moi les gens conçu qui
vous regardez cette vidéo de mon côté
j'ai regardé quelques vidéos du
précepteur qui est charles robin il ya
des choses très intéressantes sur la
philosophie là ce fut la philosophie
c'est passionnant et c'est avec beaucoup
de monde
en tout cas chez les antispécistes les
végétaliens etc enfin les vegan on
s'intéresse à la philosophie justement
souvent ils entrent par la porte de
l'éthique
ensuite il intéressant reste mais mais
voilà donc aller vraiment voir cette
scène de charles robin du précepteur il
des choses très intéressantes et je
trouve ça très bien de pouvoir parler
d'antisémitisme véganisme comme ça de
manière aussi bienveillante et en
essayant vraiment de proposer un
argumentaire intéressant et et cohérent
donc voila moi je te remercie pour cette
conversation tout simplement
ben écoute merci à toi guillaume j'ai
pas grand chose à ajouter allez voir la
chaîne de guillaume acle et éthiques
et puis et puis ben n'hésitez pas à
intervenir dans les commentaires faire
savoir avec quoi vous êtes d'accord pas
d'accord et pourquoi pas ce que c'est
toujours ça qui est intéressant ça il
faut bien que lorsque vous commentez
chers amis soyez conscients qu on vous
lit mais qu' on prête d'autant plus
d'attention à votre commentaire que vous
juste
si fier ce que vous dites parce que il
est clair que moi quand je reçois un
merci c'est super je suis très content
donc je vais avoir commencé à mettre mon
petit coeur mais par contre quand
j'entends ou quand je lis c'était nul
etc
j'aimerais en savoir plus et ça veut pas
forcément dire que vous allez nous faire
changer d'avis mais ça fait aussi partie
du jeu sur youtube de pouvoir interagir
de pouvoir proposer des arguments et
croyez bien que à 1000 abonnés ou à 60
mille abonnés on vous lit et que quand
on lit des choses parfois qui sont de
nature à nous faire nous interroger ou
voir les choses autrement on est preneur
on est vraiment preneur donc je pense
que guillaume tu me corrigera si si tu
n'es pas d'accord
exposez vos contre arguments exposés vos
désaccords mais exposer les de manière
argumentée on prendra beaucoup de
plaisir à vous lire voilà bien sûr et
puis de toute façon si jamais vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec nous il n'ya
que en nous présentant des arguments
constructif et et réfléchie qu'on pourra
changer d'avis avec juste du c'est nul
où ça n'a pas d'intérêt ou des insultes
c'est pas ça qui vont nous changer notre
argumentaire anneaux une mine aux
convictions donc que de toute façon par
définition sans un argumentaire
constructif on changera pas d'avis donc
n'a aucun intérêt à commenter de manière
négative si c'est pas pour le faire de
manière intelligente voilà beaucoup je
pense qu'on peut se laisser là dessus
guillaume caraman merci à toi pour cette
ce débat très intéressant et puis bah
peut-être une prochaine fois
carrément strike plaisir ciao
[Musique]
oh